ed of June 2024 baby District Council's
planning committee I welcome you all
here this morning and to the members of
the public which will come to you all in
turn and we will turn your mics on at
the appropriate times for the visitors
welcome to this meet and the planning
committee may I first of all remind you
of some of the domestic arrangement
these ensure that the microphones are
turned off when not in use that you do
not interrupt other speakers that if you
wish to speak point of order declaration
and or interest or request an
adjournment if they indicate this box
this should not be used for any other
purpose or conversation during the
meeting members are reminded that they
should not have alternative
communication lines open
other than scope debts and that if you
are contacted by a third party during
this application of this meeting you
should bring this to the legal advisors
attention that if you are attending the
meetin to speak and persistently
interrupt the meeting you may be asked
to leave if a member of the committee is
contacted by conducted by a third party
during the meetin that they must also
bring this to the chairs attention as
soon as possible if members do lose
connections to the meetin that they must
contact the members of port officer
Mandy Smith immediately you do all have
her number at the side with you so you
can just phone up and we would then get
you reconnected I would like to remind
everyone present that this meetin will
be broadcast live to the internet and
will be capable of repeated feareth the
whole of the meetin will be recorded
where there are confidential or accent
items if you make a representation to
the meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to be and
recall
by entering this meetin as a speaker you
are also consented to being recorded by
the council and to the possible use of
those same recordings for webcast of
and/or train and purposes the council
members of the public and press may
record film photograph or broadcast this
meet and when they are pub when the
public and press are not lawfully
excluded the introductions we have
Stephen Stroud who's azuz ejek projects
and delivery manager we all know memes
as today's chief planning officer mark
Russell the area planning manager
Elisabeth flood which is the case office
of or I believe the first one and
Samantha Salmons
the case officer for the second one or
the other way round a nd praise the
plannin lawyer who's the solicitor and
Robert Carmichael the governance officer
I will now move to the agenda I'm going
to ask for apologies for absence and/or
substitutions Rob can you please do a
roll call and tell you anyway Thank You
chair and if you just reply with good
morning or whatever is appropriate
so councillor suit airs good morning
everyone
councillor Melanie Barrett good morning
how's the Peter beer present councillor
David Busby warning notes that John
Hinton morning
sadly Jameson good morning castle
Adrienne Oswald the morning all present
councillor Alison Owen good morning just
early Parker
present counselor Stephen plum Here I am
good morning and the board members of
counselor John none morning counselor
Elizabeth male VC morning and fondly
counselor Alistair McCraw who may
present a lot of the first application
brilliant thank you
everyone is here chair and I can confirm
all the public speakers are here as well
thank you very much for that item to to
receive declarations of interest by
members or non interest are there any to
declare a figure of do a roll call again
Robin yes chair sorry
so counselor Ayres yes or no the
property at Brandt them I know the
owners or the former owners but nothing
to declare
counselor beer no nothing to pick about
councillor Busby no no no
Chancellor Osborne no declaration cows
lowing cattle Parker nothing to declare
and cows aplomb
No Thank You chair thank you
item three to confirm the minutes of the
meeting held on the 3rd of April
you've seen these are there any points
regarding the accuracy of the minutes
hmm
okay then I need to have a proposal
please in the secondary thank you that's
counselor Aires and seconder I propose
that mr. chairman in stilettos born
thank you rob you need to do a rope
Thank You chair so if you could please
respond with for against or abstain so
councillor Aires Oh Oh counts the
Barrett full beer or must be well
councillor Hinton Jameson for tell us on
McLaren Osborne for councillor Parker or
councillor plum Thank You chair that is
carried thank you very much I will move
to the minutes of meeting has been
confirmed and will be signed at the next
practical opportunity okay to receive
notification of any petitions rub thank
you
item value is site inspections officers
are there any site inspection requests
take that as a no than violence not yet
yeah okay thank you
members are there any site inspection
requests
penciler oh and didn't you want to do
one no hello sorry I didn't realize why
I had to click put it in here is for the
M you've got you've got me all going now
it's hot I wasn't expecting this
well I think there may be time this is
for the one sub Marie on the industrial
stayed I don't think it's due to come up
at the next meet and unless an officer
can correct me on that and if that's the
case you could have a word with the
officers after the meeting and bring it
to the next meetin if I'm a chance
sorry chair yeah we discussed this at
the delegation panel we have to go back
to LA councillor owns with some more
information and then we'll revisit it on
a future date lovely I know she had
mentioned it to me so so that's fine
so councillor Owen after you've had your
discussions with officer Russell you can
then decide what you want to do and go
forward there okay thank you
lovely thank you so members are there
any other site inspection requests no
thank you
then we move on to item 6 which is the
plan and applications and they were
taken in the following order lend so for
tomorrow
Acton I will now invite the case officer
Elizabeth flood to introduce the
application to the committee okay
Thank You chair I'll just share my
screen
yes that's up okay so there were no late
papers for this application but we are
aware that members of the committee have
received emails from both the developer
and the objectors this is a Sheehan for
the erection of a hundred dwellings
regular access and open space it was
first brought to Committee on lethal
March at 2020 a motion to approve the
application was lost seven four but no
motion to refuse the application was
presented the application was deferred
due to the following issues the
affordable housing should be within no
more than groups of 15 members wanted to
see additional bungalows and a decrease
in the four-bedroom dwellings
they wanted to see a decrease in the on
plot triple parking and concern was
raised relating to the proximity of the
play area to the attenuation Basin
simply revised plans which will be
discussed and then just a little bit of
clarification on the report in paragraph
3.4 where it says what failed road
frontage sorry that should say how much
road frontage can you give the page as
well I don't think I've got page numbers
on my report I'm afraid chair over 2.4
then hopefully members can follow up 28
page 28 thank you
okay so this is the site you can see
this is the damaged road here vicarage
Lane goes along here and Sudbury Road
goes here so it's surrounded by the free
the free roads and this is the old
vicarage here which is the list grade 2
listed building and you could also see
just on the edge at the corner of the
school here act in primary school
okay this is the the site plan you can
see it there are quite a number of
hedges and trees on this on the edges of
the of the development site some of
which aren't within the site here in
here hey this is the constraints map you
can see the old Rick orig the greater
listed building in this location and
then the built-up area boundary skirts
along Talmadge road and then vicarage
Lane okay this is the revised layout
following the the deferral act committee
I will just point out the the revisions
so the affordable housing has now been
split into three groups
this group of 15 here and then another
group of ten here and another group of
ten here in addition the parking
arrangements changed slightly and I'll
show you that on the parking plan the
play areas moving moves slightly further
away from the attenuation Basin again I
can show you that on another plan and
there's some additions of some bungalows
so some additional bungalows that I'll
show you okay this is the parking that
so following the concerns raised at the
previous committee the developer has
removed all the triple parking so all
the two parking spaces and garages so
all the garages with the Orang of the
pink dots and no longer included in the
in the numbers in their parking numbers
legislature for storage
an additional parking has been allocated
for these houses down here in addition
the that some over here have been
removed so all the triple parking has
been removed and some additional visitor
parking has been provided the visitors
parking is in purple
and there are 204 residential parking
spaces and 26 visitor parking spaces
okay this is the 10-year plan so this is
just to show you where the affordable
housing is located now so the red dots
show affordable vented housing and the
blue dots show shared ownership so as
you can see they're now in three
separate clusters a cluster of here of
fifteen dwellings a cluster here are ten
dwellings and a cluster here of another
this is the massing plan so following
the committee for addition of what four
bungalows have been added and the
two-and-a-half story dwellings have been
removed so you can see the four two-bed
bungalows are located free here on one
here okay this is a drawing showing the
attenuation Basin so concern was raised
regarding the proximity of the play area
to the attenuation Basin so just to
explain it this is the the play area
here which has been moved slightly and
the developer has confirmed that it
would be fenced and this is the
attenuation Basin which is proposed not
to be fenced but the profile has been
changed from one in three to one in four
and you can see here that it's quite a
low profile and the little area in below
this would be an area which would be
permanently in water of up to three
centimeters so there would be three
centimeters of water and I'm planting in
this area to provide infiltration to
keep the water clean and then the rest
of the attenuation basin would be
generally dry unless there were periods
of high rainfall when it would fill up
again this shows the attenuation Basin
so this is the area which would have
permanently standing water of about
three centimeters you can see the play
area here with the proposed fence the
developers have also proposed more trees
and planting in this location to
discourage children from you know
accessing damaged Road that will also be
the hedge
this shows the landscaping plan of the
other of the another corner of the site
and you can see that the overhead wires
are along here which is one of the
reasons why the play area wasn't
relocated to this position which is the
other area of open space directly south
of the attenuation Basin there's another
landscaping plan the landscaping officer
has asked for some addition occasion and
the developer has agreed to look at them
that that could be dealt with by
condition third landscaping plan this is
again the south of the site where you
can see the existing trees and finally
this is the this corner here so this is
quite a sensitive corner because it's
the corner closest to the listed
building and it's proposed to have brick
walls in this location rather than
closely bordered fence and some some
trees to help lessen the impact
there's also trees outside of the site
in this location hey this is just some
[Music]
elevations so this is your thing units
again another this is a terrace of
affordable housing units this is just to
show you that they are genuine generally
ten you're blind so there aren't any
differences in materials than the market
housing this is an example of one in the
market housing the design is generally
sort of arts and crafts so you get these
little details here
and again this is the bungalow ELISA
bungalows that have been added you can
see that they're too fetching bungalows
okay so these are the new street scenes
so this is a 2a is from here to here so
you get the of some of the affordable
housing which is in this location so
this is a terrace and then two blocks of
two flats each then this is the market
housing a mixture of semi-detached and
detached dwellings again more market
housing this is street scene B which is
from here to here so you can see that
and then this is street scene C which is
from here to here and you can see the
new bungalows have been added here and
here and again this is street scene D
which is location to this location and
again you can see the additional
bungalows here onto the photos this is
good looking down Sudbury Road to the
development so you can just see the
development on how much Road here so the
the fields that would be developed is in
this location okay this is looking
through through a gap in the hedgerow
onto the site so again how much Road
development is here you can see the the
field again this is looking along will
see that the hedgerows which will be
retained along here quite mature looking
back across the site so this is the
corner with a damaged road and wicked
lane here again looking so this is
Thomas very looking across the site from
the corner of damaged Road and slippery
road so this is the entire tree of the
site some of this hedge will be moved
for the visibility splays but be
relocated further back but much of this
hedging along the side will be retained
now
yeah and this is looking along the side
with with the hedgerow to be retained
okay the Sandwich rows so this is the
site the ancients would be in this
location just after the junction so you
can see here these are the houses on
Talmadge Road this is just to show you
the junction of Sudbury road with the
high street because there has been
concern relating to the the highways in
particularly this Junction as you can
see the visibility sleighs aren't on
what would be acceptable now but this is
clearly a historic Road and you can see
there have been some double yellow lines
have been put there too so to ink up to
allow as best visibility as possible and
the highway authority haven't objected
to the development again this is looking
up so pre Road onto the high street so
you can again see the sort of
substandard visibility okay this is
looking this is concerns being raised
regarding the landscape impact of the
development can just see on the edge
there that is the long well for church
so there are some long long views
particularly in this corner here looking
over the site and again this is a
slightly further up from a gap of the
hedgerow and you click on the edge and
the and the long distance view as you
move up however even these were taken in
winter and the the hedgerow is quite
strong so the views become much more
filtered and as you go along further so
as you go along here you start to see
the view context within the modern
housing a long time each road
this shows the public footpath which is
located just in this location and and
goes this way again this is damaged Road
looking at looking along the road this
is the existing hedgerow which some of
which would need to be removed and
replaced this is
looking along Sudbury Road this hedgerow
and planting would be retained and
that's the end
Thank You chair thank you thank you
forever Elizabeth that's very full now
members ocean asked you if there's any
points that you'd like clarify you'd buy
the case officer not debate but just
points and I've got one which I'll start
off with Elizabeth slide 14 Luther to a
war or Wars and I think they were on the
corner who will who will be looking
after them are they in the ownership of
some of the poor is this wall going to
be sort of looked after by whoever now
this would be garden walls it's just
rather than putting fencing up which
would which is generally what would be
proposed on that corner which is
particularly sensitive at the boundary
would be walls
that's excellent s answered it it's just
that I know some of the summer states
where they put walls between say garage
blocks and pins they've disappeared ten
years later the walls fall down and
nobody's responsible so that's fine
that's answer that members is there any
other points of clarification um can I
come in there Chancellor Ayers yes I
wondered I've mentioned other things I
found out crinkle crinkle walls are
cheaper to build an ordinary maybe a
crinkle krinkle wall this has points of
clarification is a crinkle crane called
wall or not Elizabeth
no it's just a straight wall yeah okay
any other points of clarification nope
thank you very much then we'll move on
we now have public speakers here I will
ask the parish council representatives
because councillor Graham round is that
correct you have three minutes so in
which to address the committee at the
end of that if you remain online I'll
see if there's any questions
for all you thank you when you're ready
and the justice you can hear me cooking
yeah Rob will tell you when to start and
he'll put the timer out okay thank you
when you're ready set okay acting counts
will continue to unanimously recommend
refusal of this application part three
of the officer report attempts to
describe the application site and its
surroundings the few lines of text
submit the massive recreational
contribution the site has and its
surroundings provide to the hinterland
village of Acton there is no mention of
the public sweeping country views in the
recreational value of the walking routes
the landscape officer raises concerns
regarding the visual impact of the
development the case officer seems seems
to be have a solution that just to be
and plants and more trees to hide the
development from view the misleading
report by the applicants landscape
consultants describes the site as arable
field having existing dwellings on all
full-size when in fact there is open
countryside on three sides we wonder are
they really silver in the correct
location if the application site is
developed it will sit like a carbuncle
on the outer edge of the hinterland
village and will not form a natural
extension to the village acts and
residents produced an extensive
landscape visually impacts an
infrastructure
assessment document we believe officers
have totally dismissed this important
document the document details the
extensive harm this development course
some of these are the surrounding
landscape abroad capture of the outer
edge of the village harm and Tammy's
Road owned by the parish was planted and
has been maintained for some 30 years by
the parish council the page clearly
defines the edge of the village and
provides a demarcation between the rural
landscape and the built environment the
document shows importance of protecting
the enjoyment of the rural walk from the
village centre to public right away 15
with many sweeping landscape views
across the site the walk from the centre
of the village has an incredible high
recreational value that should not be
destroyed forever 32 pages of pictures
and text described the rural scene and
the harm caused by the proposed
development massively tilting the scales
to a refusal decision when assessed
against policy
CS o - and CS 11 it's difficult to place
wave on the scales to support
approval officers mentioned the benefit
to the village the creation of a green
open space and play area the village
already has a green village green it has
a playground at a junior football area
in the center of the village it has a
very large sports greening beside the
village hall so really there is no
deficit of open space in the area the
new proposed open space is not required
it is outside of the village boundary
obviously state the 106 payments the
still payments as a as a benefit to the
local community but these payments
merely try to mitigate the shortcomings
of the application they provide notating
community or local infrastructure it's
not clear that beta policy for seal
payments has been properly assessed and
reported members today representatives
from the residents group and our ward
councillors will tell you more about
infrastructure deficits ROS safety
issues and the Balkan triumph moves to
mitigate the lack of education places
which encourage trust assist together
they result in the balance of approve or
refuse falling heavily on the refuse
side thank you for listening thank you
again sit around for that members have
you any questions for councillor around
Auckland parish council anybody
Thank You Barriss sorry yes Thank You
chairman um just wanted to clarify with
the councillor Graham you mentioned
about the loss of walk can you just with
with the assistance that's out there at
the map on site just described we're
then going to not be available is the
contribution the site makes to the walk
and the walk comes from the centre of
the village along a pathway a rural
pathway called Jennings way and then
Jennings way it meets up to tama-chan
vicarage Lane that there Bo C is the
perimeter roads of the village so once
you pass through that you're into open
countryside
emotionally people will walk through
Jennings way around the site or they
will certainly join public right away
it's 15 which takes you across to the
air
and it's a real walked because it's on
side on the side of the village
into the countryside so it's a piece of
countryside that's really associated
with the village and is used highly it
has some incredible views across the
site wherever you are
I mean offices of picked up a couple but
there's there's many more many more
thank you
Makenna Hinton Thank You chair just a
quick question on have parish council
done a wildlife survey or anything else
in that area to find out just what sort
of impact this urbanization of the
countryside will have we've heard how
they're proposing brick walls rather
than fences and yet in another
application we've got recommendations
from the Environmental Officer that we
should be putting up fences with
hedgehog holes in so there seems to be a
rather sort of eclectic view of wildlife
and its importance well in our
assessment document all the residents
assessment document they showed you know
small holes in the existing page where
you can see that wildlife do move from
the side onto the hedgerows and use the
hedgerows of coverage and that takes
them right round the perimeter of the
site of that the village at the end of
the village so it isn't important and we
still not clear what parts of the heads
are going to be removed and replaced and
in fact it's nobody it's a parish
councils head so I don't understand why
they leave they have permission to
remove it thank you for that we'll ask
the officers about the hedge at the end
of this question bit Kent Salar Parker
yeah thank you chair and good morning
council around
council around as you might know many of
the decisions that this committee
arrived at our informed either by the
existence or the emergence of a
neighbourhood plan I noticed that Acton
doesn't have one kindly attention to to
be undertaking neighbourhood plan
process I've just recently joined the
parish council and that's something that
I will certainly be push trying to push
through because there's something I
think is really missing
thank you any other questions to the
objector no thank you very much for that
and thank you can I just ask Elizabeth
can you just clarify the hage the the
objectors said that the hedge wasn't in
the ownership of the applicant and that
can you just clarify that point for us
yeah I can confirm that's been
maintained by the parish and sort of
long term but the actual land is highway
land so it is within the highway
authorities ownership and it can be
developed for the so the hedge can be
removed and the visibility's plays put
in there thank you that Clara clears
that right we'll move on then
that was the parish council I will now
ask the objector jumper so to speak you
have three burner so in which meeting
when you're ready you may start I'm
ready when you are please yes okay now
then thank you good morning government
historic environment advice from 2019
states long designated heritage assets
having a degree of heritage significance
merit consideration in planning
decisions this extends policy CNO six
the qualifying heritage building was
part of an objection in September 2019
what was admitted from Heritage
Department considering it seems in the
officer's report it's the single
dwelling it's one of the oldest houses
in Acton late 1774 servants quarters in
the vicarage sub settlement stands
across vicarage Lane directly opposite
site it's setting will be irreversibly
harmed by the proposed development that
is substantial harm as a reason to
refuse the application counselors can
you ask why this has been emitted from
the offices success
please this committee states stated
clearly on the 11th of March that you
did not want any play areas next on
attenuation Basin but the applicant
state move up area it's just sort they
didn't want to it could be put anywhere
on this open field it's clearly
understood the baseman cannot be moving
but from paragraph eight three it states
a more shallow swim will only have
thirty millimeters of water and it in
normal times what about when it can have
over a meter water how can it be used
for public open space is flooded a
police requirement system is to have a
boundary around the basin why isn't that
a condition the cows will have the same
duty of care of police to safeguard
residents the truth is not enough space
has been allocated on the site for the
right size of basin to meet the subs
formula so a supplementary crate system
has been proposed on which the flood and
water officer comments are much more
difficult this crate system appears to
be a soak away not on the ground storage
but the soil pipe means it will drain
too slowly crate systems create a need
for maintenance of basins do not they
still pop it's very hard to get the silt
out the report does not say who will
provide any maintenance on this site
except maintained by a management
company who when how in black and white
is not stated the offices report in
eight three states crates would be a
compromise nothing in the built
environment should be dim deliberately
compromised in year one to cause extra
expense in years five ten etc that is
what sustainability means in CS 15
counselors there are some some of the
clear points of planning policy on which
to base a refusal for this poorly
designed and with a hundred houses
starting shortly across the village at
borough Hill unnecessary development I'm
happy to take questions of course thank
you for listening thank you thank you
very much I know the time bar went a bit
haywire but I'd got a stopwatch here so
you had a few more seconds left that
you've used your time that you wanted to
use thank you I was
there's any questions to you on your
point of c no.6 I will ask the officer
to comment on that because obviously
it's a bit difficult for us to all be
checking our paperwork and different
things to try and get vine where it is
in the report and so I'll get the
officer to comment on that but members
is there any other questions you wish to
put forward to the object and yes hang
on I've got some here the planning
officer officer Russell you've got an
answer for Libby regard and I think C
no.6 is that correct I can provide a
nation right wait I think perhaps you
better answer that before I take the
questions from the members to the
objector okay just in case they've done
a refer to that can you just help us out
on CNO six please
six is our is the local plan policy
relating to the setting of listed
buildings and other heritage assets in
this case there is a historic building
here called higher ground the Heritage
Officer assessed the application and
from his report his concern was the
setting of the listed building the Old
Vicarage rather than listed rather than
this dwelling if he'd had concerns about
this dwelling he would have discussed
those in his response thank you
right members have you any questions for
the objector yes I have Chancellor
Harris yes I wondered this debate about
where to have the the children's play
area how would the village feel because
it's so West down there they had
allotments down though that not be an
alternative
not a question to me yeah allotments
exist at the other side of the village
adjacent to the Barrow Hill site in fact
and since the Barrow Hill site includes
a community orchard at present then I
feel that they may be growing apple
trees or they may be growing vegetables
it's it's still a point to be determined
but yes the village has got allotment
allotments could be pacer of course but
that would have to be a condition of the
plan sorry of the application and the
application would have to modify
modified in order to run to show clearly
what was expected of the developer in
terms of putting in the several options
and any other questions councillor
Parker yeah Thank You chair and again
good morning mr. purser mr. person much
of your representation was predicated on
the effective harm heritage harm however
looking in the forthcoming joint local
plan preferred options document
consultation document the proposed
development site here is actually an
allocated side so it is it your
contention that this is just a
completely unsuitable site whatever
whether it was this development or or
any other development it is when that's
in alignment with our ward councillors
and the Parish Council this field has
been batted to and fro for housing
development for the last nearly 30 years
and it's always been locked back because
it would be as was described a carbuncle
on the edge of the village it is a long
way 500 metres from the shop
it's pedestrian access unless you drive
around by the road even cycle access we
there are clearly no cycling signs on
the foot raised from the estate that it
crosses
Limetree estate down into the high
street where the shop is there are a lot
of a lot of points that are being skated
over this was put forward as a
designated point in rejoining local
Fanshawe but the joint local plan hasn't
been decided it's heavily delayed for
reasons we're all probably aware of and
until the joint local plan is clear this
it is the view of the residents that
this site should not be considered for
housing and one of the more important
points as I've tried to bring out at the
very end of my history and I think I've
got to keep you just to answer and the
question that we get I was I think
you're going into a long debate which I
can't I hey I can finish it in one
sentence these do yes the hundred houses
on Barrow Hill are going ahead thank you
any other questions no okay thank you
members thank you mr. round that's fine
who's next
Rob well I've just got you this time of
thing peeps make dump anything so I've
got a stopwatch beside me as well okay
as turn out good well done I will now
ask the applicant to speak Robert you
burn you have three minutes also
indicates the committee thank you for
the opportunity to speak my name is
Robert Eber and and I'm planning
director for blue Holmes Eastern
the scheme for actin is proposed in
accord with policy la 45 of your
emerging joint local plan which
identifies action and this site as a
sustainable location for rural housing
grants the approval of the application
was deferred in March by this committee
so that amendments to the scheme could
be sought the affordable housing should
be planned in groups of 15 homes or less
to assist with tenure blindness this
change has been made and affordable
housing is much better integrated as a
testament of our great inclusive
development we're also proposing that
all 35 of the affordable homes will be
built
ready for their first new residence
prior to the completion of just 26 of
the market homes the scheme is therefore
demonstrably placing the need for
affordable housing as a first priority
members also wanted to see some
bungalows add to the housing mix
councillor Busby asked that these be
planned as to bed bungalows rather than
as swanky bungalows as he put it this
change should be at the cost of 4 bed
homes we have made this change to the
housing mix which continues to comply
with the need assessment we've also
removed two and half story homes members
wanted to see the instance of on plot
suitable parking to be reduced allocated
triple parking while increasing overall
availability and accessibility of
parking spaces some members and
reservations about the proximity of the
children's play area to the suds
generation basin and at amateur Road
this has been resolved by by moving the
equipped play area and its visitor
parking further from the basin and
changing the landscaping proposals
although the basin is shallow and safe
the equipped area is also fenced and a
further fence will be provided to the
basin the play space will be rough but
approved so you can guarantee that it
will be safety audited the development
is guided by an energy statement to
reduce carbon emissions and to improve
the energy efficiency of homes the
scheme includes a PV solar panels
provision is also made for electric
vehicle charging points blow or pay
nearly 1 million pounds in community
infrastructure levy 15 percent of this
fund goes to the Parish Council for it
to dead
eight to its own infrastructure
priorities in addition 233 ons will be
secured by a section 106 agreement
towards education transport bus service
and public right-of-way improvements as
we move into the next stage is to
deliver this project I thank you for
putting your faith in us and ask that
you endorsed the recommendation of the
report to approve this proposal in its
amended fall thank you I'm free to take
questions if you want thank you very
much yes I'll say if there's any
questions for you and I'll start with
councillor sewers and then anybody else
can just tap in councillor Aires
no questions thank you can't elaborate
yes please I'm asked about the bungalows
that the Arrangements in the bungalow
are they going to be designed with wet
rooms and wider doorways and those sort
of arrangements that can accommodate
changing needs elderly population yes
there are the design is what is called
accessible and adaptable that's the
standard and mind you of course at all
of the homes here are two nationally
described space standards there's some
of these things as applied to the rest
of the homes on the side Thank You
councillor plum Thank You chair just one
question from me it's absolutely no way
you can move the play area to another
area of the development and I'm well
aware of a child can can drown in a few
centimeters of water and and I've had
problems with this type of thing in my
own ward I is really worrying me where
you're putting this play around
councillor Plummer I'd respect um your
concern but what there are different
types of suds areas and this area is
some a very shallow basin and it's quite
common for to be next to play area what
we have done is of course he moved the
play equipment and it's now shown as a
fenced area without that hoop top
railings around it and also we will be
proposing a fence between the wider play
area
it's just a great community space and
the suds itself even though that suds
areum is it doesn't require that to get
a Royal Society for Prevention accident
certificate so it's kind of a sort of a
double lock to prevent there being any
any incident in and I am aware as you
are of other instances where that there
are quite deep basins and that is not
what's proposed here and that's part of
a part of what the reason why there is a
sort of crater system here as well to
make sure that the scheme is quite
shallow with very shallow size so
hopefully I think that reassures you
that the scheme is not unlike many other
schemes which have this similar
relationship
Thank You councillor cups degrees chair
yep yep so the answer to my question is
quite simply no I did to me that's
that's giving me the answer I didn't
want to hear thank you
well that wasn't a question penciler
Hinton thank you chairman just let me
stop this call right got it there sorry
about that just a question for the
applicant on he mentioned the Syl
contributions was he working out his
cell contributions based on the market
housing or all the housing on the site
and does he consider that that would
solve any of the problems you've caught
of course Syl contributions are
mandatory
yeah the sill contribution is based upon
only the market housing because the
affordable housing doesn't attract a
sale contribution so yeah it's a it's a
sizeable amount and it says roughly it's
just sort of 1 million pounds of sill
which again is free for the council to
spend on infrastructure as it sees fit
and if we've I've been involved in a
number of schemes throughout babe
and in also mid Suffolk and it's quite
normal for the sill contribution to be
in excess of the infrastructure
requirements that they're claimed
against it but not a number of issues
would be resolved as a claim against
that contribution by the NHS for
instance so and also there's a claim
against a contribution for schools to
make sure they're enough school places
so there are key elements here which are
are dealt with to make sure that the
scheme washes its own face in terms of
dealing with infrastructure requirements
Thank You chair good morning mr.
reedburn could you give us some sense of
the engagement that you have undertaken
with the community to gain their consent
for this Thank You councillor Parker yes
certainly this development has been the
subject as any development which is a
standard for planning application being
subject to full public engagement we did
a public exhibition there's a statement
of community involvement submitted with
the application and of course we've had
considerable dialogue on that with
various source naturally consul tastes
and as I said with the amendments of the
committee requested on the 11th of March
to make sure we get this application in
the best possible shape and to make sure
it term it meets with our local
requirements Thank You councillor Jo
Jameson oh yeah good morning one of the
proposed conditions either for a
biodiverse in mitigation in heart and
images and I'm wondering what what you
plan to do to provide a net gain for the
biodiversity within this right Thank You
councillor Jameson basically the
biodiversity plan will be it's part of
the overarching landscape and landscape
management so we obviously we ensure
that the landscaping planting is native
planting within it also there's a number
of ecological matters I mentioned
earlier on was um hedgehog holes well
yeah we've we proposed that
throughout the development obviously
there are certain elements when there
are brick walls but which are there for
design purposes but a lot of the
development is fencing and hedges so
there's a as a general look at ecology
and how that developed the development
can have some enhancement value on
ecology and that also goes over to the
suds area which has ecological plants
again it's not just a blank area with an
area which has got wildlife dancing in
there to encourage habitats and so that
the developments it's very well in that
was in that respect thank you
I have no other counselors wanting to
put questions to to you those ones come
in Chancellor Osborne Thank You mr.
chairman on that same subject to the
applicant I've mentioned this before on
several developments I'm not absolutely
certain when I finished it on this one
it's a question so this that within
these houses if if this is approved
could put the applicant please ensure
that we have areas of Swift bricks to go
into these properties please thank you
yes what we do is with we submit a plan
to the council to officers which show
exactly where those bricks go the Swift
bricks that go and we have bird box as
well it too is slightly different and so
there'll be a plan showing exactly where
those go and there's they that gets
looked at by the wildlife trust so there
you can just check to make sure they're
on the right orientation too because we
wouldn't want to put them in somewhere
which they would be used so that's that
works very well nuts that's details to
come thank you thank you very much for
that that's an excellent answer thank
you thank you
Owen yeah just a bit couple of quick
questions really am solar solar panels
is that on every house
and the electric points how many
electric points will there be around
this date thank you
yes sir there are solar PV panels that
is a matter which is being at terminus
at the next to a technical level of
detail it really does relate to the the
orientation of the building so and what
the target is
not necessary just to have solar panels
but to have a reduction in carbon
emissions and our target level of carbon
reduction is 10% so we will achieve that
through a variety of means including
stone bowtie panels and the electric
charge electric charging sorry I'll just
thinking that you're charging me we are
we're a bit of a leader on this so our
developments all have electric charging
points and they tend to be within
garages and on plots because it's the
best way to manage them and again that
there can be a plan submitted
subsequently which shows exactly where
these will go but it will be widespread
throughout the development and so that
we are new residents are equipped to
deal with electric vehicles as it when
they see fit Thank You councillor Busby
thank you when we burn could you tell me
where on the scale of swanking us these
two bedrooms bungalows are going to fit
the Busby I think were you saying
you mentioned the word swanky I was
sitting directly behind you at that
previous committee I think what you are
what you were looking for was some was
that we didn't just propose large
bungalows which could just end up being
family bungalows I think the objective
was to have was to look at these being
occupied by older people and these
particular this particular size of on
where they are to bed bungalows and so
they fit within that area the market
this this scheme has been reviewed by
our marketing director and they're
satisfied this is just a sort of
property that the people in want to
downsize to so um we think it's a really
good improve mix so that he gets some
more smaller units in there and I will
see at your request we've reduced the
number of 4-bit homes conventionally
thank you've developed as Linton's
listen to me more often as you can see
our our counselor Busby is very good
with his use of words something here
councillor Busby's that's very good
counselor Barrett Chancellor Barrett
sorry going to ask about the electric
charging points and cants very nasty but
I think you addressed it in terms of the
the normally based in garages so will
every household to be able to charge an
electric vehicle by their house I think
that the answer that question is no
there will be in most of these
developments have a general scheme which
allows the majority to do that but in
some through designs some properties
don't really have that facility won't
want a cable running across the road for
instance so it's just done on a property
by probably basis but I would say you
did not choose the majority thank you
Jamison hello it's mentioned in the
report that underground water storage
crates are going to be introduced to add
surface water capacity the as mentioned
I think by the parish council these
require a lot of maintenance and this is
also mentioned in the report and I'm
wondering who he's going to be doing
that maintenance in the future yeah
again thank you very much this is not
unlike other schemes where which involve
this is not a it's not a new thing we're
doing here it's done the maintenance is
gets put into a management company and
there's a payment per property that for
this to be looked after and there'll be
a management plan
draftee which shows that
that the the crates and the oval
subsystem get get maintained on a
routine basis so they will be effective
for the life of the development not just
for a year or two is this on English
persists in perpetuity thank you
I there's no more questions requested in
the chat box so members if there's no
more we'll move up thank you sorry
councillor McClaren you've just come in
yeah I just want to ask mr. eben he
couldn't know know developer could have
foreseen the situation we are in in the
country and one of my concerns is
because of this large development around
action what employment prospects there
are there for the people that are going
to buy the houses I'm going to live
there a sub rial Reddy has got some
problems with its employers leaving the
town I think I think there's some
question someone goes to the heart of
the the principle of development
obviously this is a site which is
allocated for development and it's also
has very good access to areas of
employment which is led to it being
allocated in your policy la 45 it also
has very good access to the National
Cycle love route so I say there is
significant employment in locality which
will meet the needs of the local
community remembering of course that
some 35 percent of the homes will be
occupied by people who are already from
a locality because they are an
affordable housing needs so I think the
RTO practices generally this is has good
access to employment and going back to
those sort of kovat 19 crisis blow
Holmes is responding to that and we are
gradually getting back to work and
getting back to deliver sites and
obviously this is the key part of our
Rayyan economic recovery this site going
into 2021 2022 and beyond thank you very
much for that councillor Hinton
you wish to come back canceling yeah
Thank You mr. chairman yes the applicant
just mentioned the fact that the 35% of
that though the houses were going to be
for local people well perhaps he isn't
aware that we are part of the greater
Haven the housing area so we could end
up with a patís coming from chums as far
away as chums furred so it's not
reserved for local people so it doesn't
necessarily mean because you're building
social housing that it is going to be
available for local people unless it's
on an exemption site where you can then
reserve it for people with the local
connection I think your housing officer
would probably beg beg to differ the the
there is a significant housing need in
this locality which is on the council's
housing measured register for people
wanting homes wanting new homes who are
in in dire housing need and our
households it needs so I think you can
be reassured that there will be people
from the locality to need these these of
all homes and indeed need the maquis
homes mr. chairman if I could come back
I would just say then that in some of
the villages in in my area we have
residents who can't get housing next
door to existing family or near to
existing family members because the
houses seem to be allocated to people
from outside of the county even because
they have more points on the housing
scheme I would like to say that is one
of my priorities to make sure that there
is priority given to local people
particularly for affordable housing and
is the clause that I often ask to be put
into section 106 agreements to achieve
exactly that the district council does
have housing policies so that they would
come into play anyway but I would just
like to say in answer to some of the
comments just made there that I visited
the prosimians site in great cornered
that sheepshead Hill over the weekend
and I was told there was only two
properties left for sale they're all
taken and they haven't actually finished
building them yet so that surprised me
anyway I'm gonna ask the officer if
there's no other question that members
to clarify that last point Elizabeth can
you help us out yes so the proposed
affordable housing is not for local
needs so it's not just for the parish of
Acton and people surrounding it however
what we always require in the first
instance so is the very first allocation
of that affordable housing will be
prioritized the district first so where
as subsequent allocation so for the
could include people in the Haven
gateway initially it would all go to if
there is the demand it will all go to
people within the district obviously if
there is not enough demand within the
district then they would look wider okay
thank you right members
I think that's cleared up at that point
if there's no one else wishing to put
any questions to the last speaker the
applicant I will thank mr. e Byrne and
we'll move on thank you I would now ask
the ward member counselor John Donne to
address you use their had five minutes
in which to address the committee okay
thank you okay uh when on the 11th March
this committee met to debate the
application there was a definite move
towards refusal seven of you voted
against only four supported it seemed to
my residents that the committee needed a
little more time and help from officers
in formatting the many reasons raised
that support refusal so we are hoping
this time around you take a fresh look
and will carefully consider all the
information put forward by the parish
counselors with local knowledge of the
highway use residents have raised
concerns about highway safety they are
really concerned about the introduction
of a new Junction into tamid Road
residents consider it unreasonable that
the applicants highway consultants have
registered evidence of nosing
Tamm each road is fabricated and we do
not accept their solution that existing
resident should find somewhere else to
park this is ridiculous proposal the
applicants consultants and County
highways officers have survey damaged
road and brickies Lane during the
Working Day and not in the evening and
weekends
and let us not forget the new normal is
more people working from home they have
overlooked the safety concerns where
heavy parking restrict the carriageway
to a single track with no passing places
safety issues at crown Junction have
also been brushed away without proper
consideration of additional traffic from
the existing approved 100 dwellings at
Barrow Hill the traffic from 200 new
dwellings may well verge onto this busy
junction with poor visibility and
existing parking hazards we have a
member of this committee living nearby
who surely firsthand can confirm the
highway concerns health care and
education facilities are both at
capacity locally there still does not
exist the proper solution for the lack
of school places children from 200 new
homes will have to travel by car or bus
to school the proposal that still
money's will cover the cost of transport
is no guarantee that a service will ever
be provided guarantees solutions to
mitigate this education for shortfall
another concerning issue that the
current and long-term government
guidance makes it clear that walking or
riding a cycle to school should be the
new norm and certainly not bundling
children onto buses with covered 19 a
long term concern class sizes are set to
reduce more pressure on school capacity
government have put aside billions of
pounds in funds for local highways
authorities to encourage that local
journeys are made by cycle of walking
the remote location of this site will
result in many local journeys by car or
bus latest government guidance for
highway students giving for highways
authorities have been instructed that
such travel should be reduced not
increased I am really concerned that the
officer report has not assessed this
latest legislation or at least referred
to it to County highways for advice this
officer report suggests that the
the community will benefit from s106 and
sill payments the real situation is that
these monies will not benefit the
existing community or improve local
infrastructure at all these payments are
purely to mitigate the impact of the
proposed development council Busby has
already asked for a more in-depth
explanation of silt and 106 pavements
why on earth is 12,000 pound 500 pounds
of steel money being allocated to
upgrading a rural muddy path across the
redundant airfield is going to take a
lot more than 12,500 pounds to improve
the surface lighting and drainage of the
route upgrading this Pass will urbanize
the open countryside there are little or
no benefits to the existing community
from this application officers recently
concluded in a recent refused act and
planning application at Clay Hall Lane
that there was no proven need for
four-bedroom homes in the village so
again this application with its 21
four-bedroom dwellings does not have any
tangible benefits for the existing
community or wider area as it had been
said the balance of the scale should
fall heavily on the refuse side this
application has been subjected to many
errors shortcomings and last-minute
changes which has frustrated the
residents finally just to remind you
seven members voted against this
application in March so please support
the long list of reasons raised for
refusal and let us finally reject this
application thank you thank thank you
very much councillor none I think just
before I go to the ward member to the
committee members the office I have
anything to clarify on what's just been
said in relation to which points Wow
there was quite a food there wasn't
though I didn't know may I take the
first one chair about the the motion
last time that the way the debate went
there was a motion to approve and then
that that fell and it didn't then mean
it was going to be refused or the
proposal for refusal there was no
proposal for refusal what members asked
for were some changes without prejudice
what didn't mean they would support it
if the changes were made but they asked
for some changes so could then come back
and be reconsidered there wasn't a
motion yes exactly that that's the point
I want to raise there I think maybe you
can probably cover the other the schools
etc is okay so you did point out where
the school was better if you just take
that point maybe and then I'll go to the
members yeah just issue with school is
that the current forecasts show that
they would that the school is currently
got a lot of outs of catchment children
so they're hired so the County consider
that within once these and the Chernus
gone through and the outs of catchment
children and possibly siblings have been
have left there will be space for both
the children from this development and
the Barrow Hill development to go to the
school so while they are asking for
funding for transport for primary pupils
this is only for 7 years they consider
that within the seven years there will
be then space within the school for the
local children so while it's not ideal
this is not a long-term situation where
children would be bused to school
forever it would be short within 7 years
and those forecasts also do include the
barrel hill development and it's not
clear which one of these two will happen
first the barrel hill still requires its
reserve matters thank you and just
before we go to the members and I'll
start with Suez in a moment is that
canceller none you did refer to 212 I'm
assuming you're referring to the Barrow
Hill as well as this one because this is
only a hundred dwellings and I have to
remind members that we are dealing with
the one in front of us which is a
husband yes Peter that was a combined
figure Thank You councillor Ayers do you
wish to speak against Lowen
yes please I was just say about the
schools and everything because we're
with the school says you haven't got any
space at the moment but all this was
decided before the koubek 19 surely is
changed now surely we've got to go back
I've got to stop you there it's a
question to the ward member and that
that sounded like a question in debate
for the officers to respond to oh yeah
that's what I put my can I speak when
Elizabeth was speaking up I'll come back
to you then when we go into debate okay
thank you
is there any questions to counselor John
on the ward member to members the
committee nope okay move on and we'll
now ask the other ward member can select
Elizabeth no phases you also have five
minutes in which to address the
committee so your time starts now
thank you sorry Thank You mr. chairman
and good morning everybody
last time we were here you rejected this
application 74 it was then deferred but
at that time I was discussing climate
change and it had to influence our
thinking however little knowing how our
world was about to change we do need the
right house in the right place but this
development fits neither and yet nothing
has changed in Acton because there is no
demonstrable needs assessment nobody has
asked the village of actin and the
residents of Acton do you want a hundred
houses Cova derived and it's now changed
if not just for now but also the future
because it's here to stay so what are we
going to do about it
how are we going to build in a way that
does not encourage it to rampage like it
has done Cobra do was rampant in places
high density so planners and councillors
required courage and vision to ensure
that we create living space that will
help prevent its content
once I ask this committee to have that
vision and reject this application
because it does not provide what is
needed for now and in the future it's
been kicking around Steen and it's taken
ten months to get to be in front of you
this development plus another already
granted will increase the number of
homes in Acton by 20% is this consistent
with policy CS 11 does it match local
needs this counts almost like as
committee recently rejected another act
and development of four-bedroom houses
on offers on officers recommendation
that Acton did not need four bedroom
houses well which is it to be is the
release or isn't now visual impacts
ability to integrate the del of
development into the landscape does it
do that
no it stands out like a carbuncle how
does it comply with CS 10 which states
that it should not exceed identified
need and be suitable in size and scale
but the officers have already said there
is no need so why is there a need you
asked the bungalows be included can I
remind the applicant that bungalows are
not just for elderly people bungalows
are also for young people but none of
these are affordable the triple parking
replaced with garages that look like Sat
1970 standards in size however maybe
this is the developers attempt to
dissuade car youths which I commend the
sentiment for not in the actuality the
application would sit well in suburbia
not in a rural setting on the edge of
the star Valley a crammed design in a
rural setting and I stressed the crammed
because of kovat the play area was to be
away from the attenuation basis the
request has been ignored affordable
houses tend to be sought by young family
and end of the development and the play
area is at the other
near the basin Anna sudbury wrote and if
you've got children I had four they do
not stay they climbed through hedges and
up trees and they cross roads so why not
put the center of developer of this end
put the play area in the center of the
development keeping children safe and
thereby complying with policy 21 you
asked but you've not totally got it
despite swapping some market affordable
houses they're still not pepper pop Bob
potted or tenure blown blinders policy
requires fifteen dwellings one end in a
cul-de-sac and it's a dedicated
cul-de-sac totally contrary to location
and operational advice given yet
incorrectly supported in this layout
approached by officers report document
paragraph six for why has recommended
for approval being giving to you with
this glaring error can officers
explained to the committee why this
substandard evidence has slipped through
and yet it begs the question what else
has slipped through council abuzz he
asked for clarity regarding sill and
section 106 maybe he has received it now
I wholly concur with counsel and on
twelve and a half thousand for a
footpath is totally insufficient when
it's flowing across a field
but Kovac 19 is here and Kovac 19 should
be making everybody think of what
they're doing and not doing you have the
flexibility it is in your power reject
it once and for all you've been given
all the reasons and planning policy to
so do this is wrong houses in the wrong
place crammed and just waiting for
covert nineteen to Festa thank you thank
you very much right you've said quite a
lot I think they're food questions to
this tense counselor Busby you've got a
question to the ward member thank you
yes Lee she brought in Kovac nineteen
quite a bit there and what are the
feelings that come out of it is that
people will be working from home more
and more and therefore require become a
dedicated workspace and therefore that
I'm loath to cast say that could be a
need for four bedroom houses where
perhaps one of those rooms is actually
used as an office so how do you feel
about that counsel and Busby I totally
agree with you but the point I was
trying to make was that there has been
an application submitted for four
bedroom houses and these were rejected
by the officers the recommendation from
the officers was to reject the
application the application rejected now
now they're saying well we'll keep these
four bedroom houses here but we don't
want those four bedroom houses there so
it's the contradiction thank you I will
get the officers to answer that point
after we've finished with questions to
you counselor my basing any other
members wish to request counselor power
no sorry canceller Barrett thank you um
question for lismo VZ um hello Liz um
can all interpret effect on future in
many surveys and I'm sure it won't in
many different ways I think it's quite
possible that it will lead to even more
need for affordable houses as people
find their incomes future affected do
you do you think that could be should be
taken into account yes and I do there is
scientific evidence now that
demonstrates the kovat 19 Fester's
multiplies in crammed so in high-density
living areas affordable housing is
needed but it needs space around them in
doesn't need they don't this shouldn't
be at the end of a cul-de-sac crammed
into a tight space had the play area
being in the sin
of the development it would have offered
a visual better aspect it would safety
for the children and it would have been
easier to Pepperpot
the affordable housing to achieve social
mix and thereby discourage kovat to
fester thank you
I think some of this Kovach my team is
sort of a hearsay they're not actually
proven facts and things I think we have
to bear that in mind as well members I i
disagree mr. chairman there is
scientific evidence on the well that
their baby as I said this is different
views so I think we have to weigh them
all up cancelar Parker yeah I think
you're just sticking with the Cova theme
if we're now going to use kovat as as a
planning measure how does counsel ml VZ
square that with the fact that the we
just all spent ten weeks at home
specifically to reduce the transmission
of of ghovat very good point
yeah the screen keeps on I don't know
whether you can hear me or not yes the
screen that's controlled elsewhere okay
right um how do I square that because it
was a one size fits all when they didn't
know how it operated now that they now
that they know that it works in crammed
high-density living areas I would think
that the policy would be different but
when you don't know what you're dealing
with and you're in a tunnel and it's a
bit dark and you can't see the end of
the tunnel because there's no light they
took a decision or the government took a
decision and went there I would suspect
that if there is a second wave and I I'm
of the belief that there will be a
second wave and then the policy will be
slightly different because they have
learnt hopefully from their mistakes
they have watched the virus how
travelled and how its disseminated
itself in society and therefore it will
be it will be different supplementary
charges quick yes yes yes so councilman
fees you'll bill be aware that we don't
have anything within our planning
guidance that allows us to consider this
application based on on co-ed so do you
think is the straight yes or no do you
think that we should support or reject
this application based on on covert 19
you asked me if I think well I was asked
if I think and I do think I'm homeless
at Ian's Thank You members you have to
interpret that as you feel fit any other
questions to the member no right then
we're going to move into debate before I
do that I see officer Russell wishes to
comment Thank You chair and you can hear
me I hope yes yes yes just to advised
that there there is there has been bits
and pieces of guidance coming out from
government about Co V but it's all been
about temporary measures to keep things
going
it's been that sort of thing we haven't
to my knowledge had anything saying our
decisions must now be based on a some
different future so there's not a
there's not a piece of planning guidance
to my knowledge which should also the
decision we make today about this
application thank you and if you want to
talk about the density now we can do
that or do you want that to come out in
the debate I think we'll go into debate
okay I intend to start cancel a Busbee
can I just ask you can your question be
directed in the debate or do you do want
to do it now
separately can be done in the debate
thank you I will come into debate I'll
come to you but I did promise fund that
I'd come back to her
because you've got will going to debate
now so if you'd like to go into bait you
can put your questions and views and
comments and then the officers will
answer okay
cancel it Owen yeah and house only just
go pick 19 surely the County Council may
be an update on the schools because
obviously Acton now still hasn't got the
capacity they needs and it's gonna go
over a few years so surely the class
sizes are going to go the class sizes
are going to beard not as many and it's
not gonna be just this year it's gonna
be for a few usually I reckon surely
that's got coming to consideration I
believe officer Elizabeth flood did
answer that but can you help us out on
this Elizabeth yeah I mean clearly the
the the county forecasts of of school
places it's based on the the normal
situation which is generally thirty per
class I would be very wary of thinking
that anything else is going to be long
term clearly we want these houses to be
there if you know if they're approved
though they were probably hopefully well
built and they'll be here for you know
seventy years so I think we do need to
be out looking at a short term impact if
long term you know schools can only have
15 per year then there will be a massive
change to all school forecasts and you
know there have to be a doubling of
school numbers or school sizes and
that's going to have a massive impact so
I I think wary of looking in terms of a
long term decision about this thank you
can't elaborate thank you I'm chair I I
have to bring to your attention that
acting school is not at capacity it has
place at capacity for 200
ten pupils individuals gear groups some
of those might be classes might be full
but the overall number of pupils
currently registered to attend that
school is 177 so it's well below
capacity and that's even with out of
pupil out of catchment pupils attending
so some some of those pupil those places
were didn't include the out of catchment
pupils it will be well below capacity
and schools do not thrive very well when
they are not at capacity because they
the numbers don't don't support full
employment of their staff so really need
to bring everyone's attention to that
because that is that is public knowledge
and some of the ward members don't know
this right okay that's a good point
councillor Busby you were next yep going
back to the console and section 106
debate look on page 35 section 12 it
talks about the County Council wanting a
contribution towards this schools
transport which he says cannot be
provided by SIL are we saying that that
will be provided by section 106 because
I'm very suspicious of money that the
counts that County Council get which is
supposed to be used for schools
transport because they haven't got a
very good record on continuing their
promises but if it's a section 106
contribution then surely this will be
tied to that specific need your your
always concerned about the County
Council cancel it and get you an answer
Elizabeth can you help on this yes this
would be 106 funding I've spoken to the
county and they Mason from the
government that they can lawfully ask
for this sort of funding for 106 and one
is expanding for this sort of transport
I also asked them if they had any
examples of where they have
this money and they've said that it's
relatively short thing that this has
only been a short time that they've
asked for it so they haven't gotten any
examples yet where they've had the money
that the development has started and
they abused it but they are confident
and is it will be part of the legal
agreement so the county can only draw
down on it they can only ask the
developer for it if they can show that
it is genuinely going to be used for
primary school transport thank you
penciler Hinton Thank You mr. chairman
um just on that on that last point
reading the the county councils
responses to education on before they
don't seem to think this capacity for
this development and the Barrow Hill
development perhaps the primary school
so councillor Barrett's point is
probably a little bit subject to
interpretation by different bodies the
County Council are saying it's fall
we've got to take them sevenths for
seven years to somewhere else a bit
difficult to try to figure out who wants
what then they're also saying this money
is 106 linked for taking them to the
primary school pupils somewhere else
what about the secondary school pupils
because there's no no mention of funding
for them other than a five hundred
thousand SIL request which is going to
be put in for secondary education but
nothing to say about transport of those
people the other thing about this
application is that under CS 11 core and
hinterland villages Acton's a hinterland
village to assume that it's part of
Sudbury on long Melford z' cluster and
therefore is liable for some of the
housing deficit of those two two areas
is a little bit disingenuous and Marla
dumps houses in the countryside which is
what we've been doing as a council for
years where 60% of all development has
been taking place in the countryside no
there's been no comment on this
application from the NHS and yet the
doctor's surgery at long Melford I
presume it's full as most of them are
the sub REE ones are probably fooled and
certainly they're talking
and possibly moving further away from
this towards the the south so there's
there are problems there and there's
employments a problem as well we've seen
employment disappear in in Sudbury and
yet here we are putting houses in the
middle of the countryside and saying
they can be employed CS 11 says that he
should contribute towards the employment
as well as the housing needs of an area
well there's no employment going to come
from this other than from out of
district builders who come in do the job
and then disappear again thank you for
that John on officers I think I'll have
to come to you to answer those questions
but before I do to give you a moment to
think about what kinds of Hinton has
just asked councillor Park has got a
question on a sale we came next and then
perhaps I'll bring you officers in
afterwards
Kent's lopaka you have tanki champ and
forgive me I'm pouring through the
report can't I can't immediately say it
but what it actually is the sill
contribution for this development
because just a point that council and
none raised earlier about you know the
lack of infrastructure spending but of
course 15% of any silk contribution here
will come back to the to the community
it would be 25 if they had a Nightbird
plan in place and and the remaining 85%
of course is available for any village
any community to into to offset some of
the you know the impact that's caused by
by the development so I think it's a bit
disingenuous to say that that the
village won't and the community won't
benefit from it that is absolutely not
the case
they've been significant sums of money
have been contributed as a direct result
of Syl - back into communities and as I
said as I reiterate the parish of acting
will receive 15% of this straight
straight into their own coffers yes now
I'll go to the officers can you answer
these last couple of points from
counselling Hinton and Kinsler Parker
please mark him so that after so raffle
of
Russell yes could you repeat the
question or questions I have several
here and I'll answer them well hopefully
you've made a note I have but there are
so many which one would you like to
begin and go through them please okay
there was a question about about SIL and
I think probably has just been answered
in the chat box the actual figures I
think Iran is it page a7 but I think
there's actually a I thought there was a
box on page 47
yeah it does that the box on 47 breaks
down where the money would go I've
spoken to this sorry to break in but
page 47 is actually the application form
for anthem Alcorn it's run through sorry
yet page 37 as you were okay
sorry you got that good that's their
answer to what is the total contribution
was the question its color past utility
because she's she's the case officer
she's got the information is that right
Elizabeth keen dear thank you so there's
two sets of funding there's the 106
funding which is set out in the proposal
and that is the funding for the school
transport the bus improvements and the
and the the possible funding for the
public right-of-way if it's not provided
by the Chilton woods development and
just to be clear that public
right-of-way we're not proposing to the
county is not proposing to light it and
so on because that wouldn't be
appropriate in a rural setting it's just
to improve the surface to make it as on
howard-browne surface in relation to to
the SIL money I mean that there will be
a summer there will be a sum of money
from sale that hasn't been completely
calculated and it's but and there has
been requests from the county council in
terms of school funding and
from the NHS for funding to potentially
expand the long Melford practice and if
it's not possible to expand that
practice to look elsewhere for health
care expansion right thank you
so did you want to come back at all yeah
I think there was a little discussion
about where the money would go and how
its channeled I've had a discussion with
the silting today just for confirmation
just for everybody's information 5% of
the SIL money goes towards
administration so that's you know the
paperwork 20% of it goes towards
strategic needs across the district and
the remaining 75% is ring-fenced two
items relevant to that village so it
doesn't mean the money goes in that
village but it would be things that
would be relevant to that village so for
example you know education would be for
example of expanding the size of a
school nearby to accommodate the the
pupils that sort of thing so that's how
it's spent hopefully that clarifies that
point thank you right members they're
still in debate is there any other
number that wishes to make comments yes
please I can't elaborate thank you um so
we're in debate now
okay so we've heard quite the concerns
but we do have to weigh up and balance
it all out and and look at the benefits
as well which and there are the
affordable elements that this this
provides so for me I might the the
issues that were raised in March have
been addressed that although the play
area is still in the same corner as the
attenuation basin that it is fence it's
going to be fenced people should fill in
that reassuring rather than just
rejecting it really I think
at the March meeting the strategic
manager Julie Abbott Abey Abey Taylor
talked about the need for one-bedroom
units since the Universal Credit I think
it was called the bedroom tax altered
people's benefits in line with the
number of bedrooms they had in their
properties so that there is a definite
need heritage issue that needs to be as
the barrister at our training last year
talked about demonstrable harm so that
is that is a I think more more
definitive than just saying harm I don't
think there is demonstrable home to the
Heritage a sir I think it it's it's you
know an acceptable level proximity
I think the villagers still have the
foot that's near to the site
so although the views have will change
the views are still available through
the other side of the site it is an
allocated site its sustainable in terms
of the village amenities shop baths
school employment in bull Lane and
supper II there's a good mix well do
welcome the addition of the bungalows
and although councillor Busby you know
talks about swanky but I think a level
of comfort is absolutely essential to
encourage people to downsize and move
out and not block those larger houses
that that can then be released back into
so for families to you to move into
solar electric charging that seems you
know what we would expect to see also
highways issues I think the concerns
people have about highways and movements
well as we've said we've heard a lot of
movements daily for children here are
out of catchment being they must be
dropped off by by car in
going along sammich wrote which is the
main access road to the school that may
reduce if more pupils from this village
attend their village school so we have
to balance out there isn't all one-way
traffic of more and more cars we could
see less traffic movements with that
that happening I then have to address
this issue this issue about coverage and
people's concerns and I I think it's I
think it's you know really wrong to
bring bring this in and suggest that
we're putting people at risk by building
houses in a certain way I think it's
totally outrageous and I I thoroughly
reject that I think that's a knee-jerk
reaction to to what's perceived as a you
know a long-term threat and we don't
know that and it could be the it's
disappears as quickly as it came in to
to this country so all I would like I'm
moving towards supporting this i've sat
through a lot of information this
morning we sat through a lot of
information in march and I are moving to
towards approval I'd like to hear what
everyone else says thank you thank you
very much Chancellor I was born yep
thank you very much mr. chairman yes I
tend to agree with everything that
Melanie is spoken about a false wall I'd
like to I'd like to thank our offices
for the work that they did with the
deferral of the application with the
applicant and way of going forward with
all four of his of the things that we
asked for resolved also of course the
the percentage of carbon content on the
houses that that were there and also the
the page 37 which on completion
if the
groan if the application was approved on
completion of an illegal agreement I
think I think everything has been done
that we asked for in those areas I can't
see any reason from what's been brought
forward today previously from the
deferral to attach it to to not to
approve this this this application and
and and I very disappointed that if
members cannot bring themselves to to to
put housing on I mean a lot of occasions
that that Sabri are going to have to
take the brunt of a lot of more housing
which it can always be done however you
know we we've not got that amount of
space in Sudbury anymore so I think
these are good sound judgment by the
developer on what was discussed with the
offices and I congratulate Liz it on
Elizabeth's flight for bringing this
forward with the developer Thank You mr.
chairman thank you right I've got
councillor Hinton Thank You mr. chairman
just a quick comment first of all to
just looking down the list here oh yes
it's Elizabeth Malvasia says there is no
housing deficit in in long Melford well
I'll just draw her attention to three
point nine of the report on page 31
where long Milford's lumped in with
Sudbury as a dirty great big cluster and
that there's a housing deficit there
that's why they're dumping them in the
middle of the countryside called act and
I do not know but also to come back on
this business about kovat nineteen
everybody's been working from home yes
who could a lot of those who have been
furloughed are now founding that finding
that they haven't got a job we've seen
two of the biggest employers in Sudbury
disappear so we're an earth are all
these people going to work if they're
not working from home and not everybody
can work
home the two major employers in Sudbury
who have just disappeared neither of
them could offer home working to their
to their employees if they were still
operating because they were engineer one
was a bit a big engineering company and
you can't do that from a computer at
home it's a hands-on job also when
talking about Kovac and the design of
developments etc this was now of a C's
quite right we should be encouraging
more open development more logical
development because is obvious from the
statistics so far and if anybody's
looked at the statistics for Suffolk
East Suffolk and sorry West Suffolk and
Baber are the two lowest instances of
courage 19 in this county its which is
one of the highest well what's the
difference between intersection Baber
once an urban area and once a rural area
so there must be some sense in the fact
that we are isolated to a certain extent
from our neighbors to start off with
which make things safer and perhaps we
should be doing a little bit more of
that in the design work so there's a lot
going to come out of this this kovat
business the things that's obvious from
the buses that go past my house at
infrequent intervals now is that they
are empty people are not using them
they're using their cars to go anywhere
because it's safer in from the health
point of view so what are we going to do
about that are we going to encourage
your PD to get out there in their cars I
also find it a little bit disappointing
that we don't have somebody from county
highways to answer questions about some
of their comments because liked it with
their comments and they can be very
vague and they can be very disingenuous
when it comes to comments about highways
nature they don't tend to do an awful
lot of the 24/7 surveying of road speeds
and traffic movements they tend to do it
as spot times and those spot times if
they are solution when the traffic is
low so I think we've got to look at
getting them on board when we moved into
endeavor house and I know we're not in
endeavor house at the moment
but when we moved to endeavor house it
was said well we'll be in the same
building as highways
so we'll be able to have them at our
planning meetings and be able to ask
some questions what happens as soon as
we move into endeavor house highways
move up to landmark house at the top of
the top of lips which away from us so
we've got to have a little bit more
accountability from the co respondents
and I would just ask Elizabeth when she
was talking about the NHS a provision
that it would have to be somewhere else
if he couldn't be at a place that wasn't
expanding there's no mention in the
report on this particular development of
is about the NHS at all yet one of the
things that Co bid 19 is gone is
certainly going to do it's going to make
the NHS work in a different way thank
you thank you John and I will ask
Elizabeth to come in but just to point
out that we did discuss highways come
and taken part in the meeting and the
our officers felt that they've got all
the information they needed and they
didn't think that was necessary for
highways to attend today so I don't drop
Peter so if I ask the officers have they
got a 24/7 traffic movement survey done
on mouth on tannaz Road or on the South
B Road in the village presumably they I
will try and get you an answer I don't
know where you got cut off there
certainly wasn't me Elizabeth can you
help us hello hi yes sorry I was just
looking to see to check that the NHS
comment was put in the report I'm pretty
sure it was but I would need to get and
that's that they have said that they
would need more much more funding for
for a GP surgery either to expand long
Melford or that's not practical to
expand elsewhere and the click here
clear place here would be in somewhere
in Sudbury which where there are health
centres and there are some which are
capable of expanding if required so
that's it in terms of yes page 23
apparently has got lis NHS comments yeah
and I mean we do have to be a bit
careful about
we talk about self funding because
obviously we we don't know it's a
bidding process and we can't say it's
going to go to a certain area but yes
the NHS has requested funding which is
which they could bid on for this
development thank you and the if I could
come back on that point on the point of
the engage in the offices of Highways to
this meetin you felt at the brief and
that you'd you were satisfied that you
got the answers can you help John out on
that yeah I mean I can't say without
having to go through all the highway
reports whether they did do Road because
that might not be so wanted they
generally want the the surveys to be
done on the the you know the more the
busier roads rather than the road next
to the development but I can't say that
for sure but the highway officer has
looked at the application they did go
out at peak times which is what was
requested and they commented that there
they don't think that this is refusal
ball on highways and you know as you are
well aware that the bar for highways is
high now
so although the the junction with the
Sudbury Road and how the high street
junction isn't brilliant and you know
we've so we've said that they don't
consider it to be a severe impact which
would prevent this which would allow
them to recommend refusal on this
application thank you I have some
speakers now so I'm going to cancel er
makind
you're next Mary yes thank you chair and
want to support what councillor Barrett
said about the developers did respond to
the request we made of them in March and
I am very impressed with that the other
comments I want to make is about the
density there was a comment made about
the density or the nearness of the
houses for the affordable housing may be
something that is for you
dude as dense in a rural area but I've
lived in denser places than that so I'm
not sure that that's an argument the
other thing is as an ex health service
person were in the middle of a in motive
period about Kovac 19 but I do not think
I do not agree with it being raised as
an issue to the planning committee thank
you very much
councillor Jameson yeah thank you sure
that's slightly different you to cancel
McLaren and councillor Brett and yes has
taken air coming on board and they they
have made some changes but the play area
is hardly been moved and while the
affordable housing has beaten split up
I'm still uncomfortable with that a
collection of affordable properties in
the northeast corner
I think the everything could have used a
bit more imagination and although yes we
asked for 10 to 15 properties they could
have divided them up a little bit more
I'd also like to ask if a four-bedroom
house is affordable even it's just
because he's renting does that make it
affordable you could still be a
statement officers did you wish to
comment on anything you've heard the the
guidance for the affordable housing says
that the maximum number should be 15 so
I think you know that's that's what
they've done there is one cluster which
is the maximum but it is in accordance
with our guidance and it's for the
housing for the registered providers it
does help them in terms of management to
have housing in clusters because you
know they can own the bits at the side
and so on so there is some management
benefits of having
them in small clusters if you literally
have them all 35 split around the site
you would find it would be harder for
them to be managed and they'd probably
be more expensive because things like
the driveways would have to be within
the management company of the overall
site which can cause issues so that's in
terms of the clustering in terms of the
four-bed affordable that's what the
strategic counseling officer requested
and clearly you would only get a
four-bed house if you had a very large
family because they don't like them to
be under occupied and therefore you
would while it might still be expensive
rent the strategic housing officer
clearly feels there is a need for one
large dwelling as an affordable thank
you
cancel aplomb Thank You Jer um just a
couple of comments one name or two or
three former housing in blocks they're
just in smaller box I think that would
block the pepper pot that play area
fences children's season as an adventure
I would I want to see this player away
from the attenuation pond in the middle
of the site
I can't accept anything less and I will
make the comment of its artist Corbin
nineteen is real it is having impacts
that we've got to start taking on board
or otherwise we're going to be in the
position of the rest of the countries it
will be too late
thank you but I think I have to remind
members you heard the planning officer
say that Cove at nineteen isn't a
recommended planning reason so yes we
can make comments please weigh them up
this is what you have to do now I
haven't had any proposals or anything
somebody else has just come in that's
councillor Parker Thank You chair yeah
so if I can just add my fault Kenneth's
into the debate chair so you know
repeatedly say as a planning committee
we have to take decisions based upon
planning balance and the you know the
rules that sit before was the planning
guidance that sits before us and he the
officer has identified within the report
that this development and I concur
actually with the officer that the
development represents sustainable
development and the NPP F is quite clear
that we're sustainable development is
identified for decision-taking purposes
that means of proving the development
proposals that are called with and how
to date development plan without delay
so do we have an up-to-date development
plan well clearly with there is a
development plan in place and we do have
the emerging joint open plan which
carries limited white as we know but
from this is the most important thing
again is that so many of our communities
now are allowing us as a committee to
inform our decision based on the
existence or the emergence of their own
neighborhood plan in this example we do
not have the neighborhood plan
councillor Mel VZ said as the residents
of act and whether they want 100 houses
well I'm quite sure that that that
hasn't happened to any great extent but
the important thing here for me
chair is that we don't have a plan to
guide us and so therefore the only plan
that is available to us to make a
decision on is our existing local plan
and based on that I think that the side
issues being that actually to me this
looks like an eminently deliverable site
it is an allocated site within the
forthcoming joint local plan that has to
be taken into consideration as well the
developer has responded to this
committee's comments from March we asked
the developer to go away and make
amendments now we did that without
prejudice but the developer has gone
away and he has he's fulfilled what this
committee asked him to do so I can firm
councillor Barrett on this and I'm
leaning very heavily in favor of
supporting the officers recommendation
from a pure planning balancing point of
view chair so that's my comment for now
thank you
I have next Adrian I was born followed
by Melanie ballot which I will come to
buy for you in the moment but the
officer Russell wishes to clarify a
point so I'll do that now
Thank You chair yeah one is always
conscious of not contributing to the
debate but just clarify some facts
before the debating procedure and etc
just just to clarify the members that
and you note those already the applicant
did describe the site allocation and the
policy relating to the site the JLP is
at an early stage so that is of limited
weight you have to consider that
although it does show direction of
travel barrow Hill
I think Libby mentioned this the
reserved matters hasn't been applied for
yet so the likelihood of that coming
along soon it's it's not a given they
are experiencing some problems with the
suds so we don't know if it will happen
that's that's the most we can be on that
site strategic housing agree to the mix
so that's that under the for bed
scheming CLE Lane was only four bidders
it was a completely for bed scheme that
that was one of the reasons that it
wasn't acceptable not not the mere fact
of four bidders it was completely for
bed scheme the density of calculated at
the gross density of approximately
twenty nine per hectare 29:29 1/2 the
hectare so it would seem not to be hence
Syl I think we've covered I won't go
back on that point jobs the point was
raised about the loss of employment in
Sudbury but we have to consider that the
children would cite and I've been
correspond with steamed Stroud just to
confirm it's got permission there's a
land promoter acting on behalf of
employment land so they're coming on
stream in children woods so there is
some employment there the last point
sorry it was just about just to confirm
what we can't understood about the
long-term concerns and the scientific
the feelings behind Co vid we've got no
guidance nothing to thirst we should
make our decisions differently because
of it so we must not consider that thank
you thank you very much right you've all
heard that I'm going to cancel Osborne
let's thank Thank You mr. chairman and
yes I listen to and read through all the
paperwork and I agreed with with Melanie
birth and and Lee Parker that they have
made great efforts to actually come up
with the resolving of problems that we
had on the referral and I would either
proposal secondly the for this to go to
the vote thank you
well approval you you have to do one or
the other you can't give me a proposal
mr. Wright so would you like to do that
for me please
yes yes I would like to take the
officers recommendation for approval of
this of this development and once again
thank them for the the effort that they
put into the presentation thank you
recommendation by canceller Osborn
consider Barrett you wanted to come in
thank you
yes I'd like to second that just just a
want to points as I spoke quite early in
this debate and I think it is not
acceptable to change the goal posts the
developer has split up the affordable
and they're now no more than 15 in in
one location then stipulated that we we
have another condition once they've met
the first condition that we provided
also on the fencing over at the last
meeting we wanted it the play area
essentially to be safe for people's
children to use I think the develop has
as address the safety issue if you if
you want to dictate the layout of a site
then I think that should have been clear
what you actually wanted at the last
meeting so again second in this
application thank you
right members have had a proposal and is
there any other comment that any men
the wishes to make no okay right I
intend to put the proposal to accept the
officers recommendation as in your
papers which has been proposed by
councillor Osborne and seconded by
Councillor Barrett I will now ask the
officer to do the roll call and he will
explain the procedure from here thank
you Thank You chair Rob
so if members could please respond with
four against or abstain mr. Duprey can
you just confirm that you're also taking
note of vote yeah hello hello Robert I
was just my internet went down I was out
for a couple of minutes but I'm back in
now so yes I will count with you and
sorry I don't think I might I'm not a
voting member the committee so my
absence for a very short while is not a
legal issue and then Rob will declare
the result of thank you
and I approve councillor melanie Barrett
for councillor Peter beer or just David
Busby counselor John Hinton
against reluctantly vote for for
counselor Adrienne Osbourne for
counselor Alison Owen counselor Lee
Parker for a family counselor Steven
plum engage motion is carried share the
application is approved and yes this is
Ian Despres I agree carried and I'm a
good eight to three is that correct yeah
yes chairman thank you very much then
that motion is carried
that application is finished with we'll
move on but before we do that I'll give
members a five-minute break it just in
case they need a comfort break and then
we'll move into the second planning
application you're happy with that yes
let me tell you the time
11:43 five minutes
you
yes chair give me two seconds and I'll
get there just moving stuff around on my
screen okay can I just check that you
can hear me before I start my
presentation okay thank you
if you Sam if you change your
presentations you at the bottom like
that yeah yep you got it so right so
counselor SUEZ present counsel Barrett
present present counselor Owen prison
counselor Parker wasn't and counselor
plum you just confirmed that you're also
present and mr. Edward Gittings and
Sophie kittens yes I'm here yes present
Sophie get ins thank you very much sorry
about that Rob thank you very much all
of you for confirming that well then
they'll go to six B which is Brampton
place Manningtree
Suffolk I'll ask the case officer Sam
summers Samantha summons to induce their
patient to the committee over D Huez
Samantha okay thank you good morning
everyone
item two can be found on page 41 of your
agendas thank you okay this is a pool
planning application seeking permission
for a conversion of
existing dwelling in six apartments and
the erection of a further 15 dwellings
within the grounds of Grantham place
extensive pre-application advice has
been carried out for this site
members may recall carrying out a site
inspection on a very very rainy day last
year the application site is to the
north of the village of Grantham this is
the site location plan and brenton place
that dwelling is centrally in the plot
the site is outside of the built-up area
boundary which you can see marked in
brown just here there is a public
right-of-way along the southern boundary
that links the site to the village there
is a pedestrian gate currently
positioned just here the grade 2 star
listed church is here and a separately
listed litigate just here which is grade
2 the whole site is within the extension
area of the Suffolk coast and Heath's
area of outstanding natural beauty there
are no on-site
however the M protected trees can be
seen just here on the constraints plan
and all are outside of the site as I've
already said there is a public
right-of-way which runs along the
southern boundary of the site and the
pathways continue and give access to the
school just here and also access can be
gained to the co-op store the main
constraints of the site are that is
outside of the built-up area boundary
the site is within the extension area of
the aom B it's a heavily wooded site
with mature trees ecology on the site
includes said
species of bat there's the grade 2
listed sorry to stylistic church and the
grade 2 lychgate Wrentham place is
considered to be a non designated
heritage a sent by our heritage team
church lane is narrow impact on the
residents of cedars closed because the
fight is actually elevated from the
nearby properties on the western
boundary surface water drainage has been
brought up as an issue and also foul
sewage disposal when members carried out
their site inspection
this was the scheme the original scheme
there was put forward at the moment
there's two access points here and here
and it was decided that this would be a
pedestrian only and then the main access
point would be on the corner of Church
Lane the houses were to cover the whole
site almost and curved around the site
all along this western boundary with
cedar closed due to issues that were
raised during the consultation process a
number of changes to the layout have
occurred as you can see from this aerial
photograph the southern part of the site
is heavily wooded and there is a lot of
mature trees in May the northern half of
the site is less densely planted
historic England felt the building
around here and bringing development
closer to the church would be
detrimental to the setting of the church
the a OMB team felt the removal of the
trees and building along this boundary
here which would open up the wider views
across the landscape would impact the
setting of the area of outstanding
natural beauty the agent has come back
with a revised scheme and all of the
development has been moved to the
northern section which is less densely
wooded and there was also a little gap
in the trees here
to further dwellings are proposed so
this heavily wooded area around here
which members may recall walking along
which to give them use across the
landscape all of those trees are to be
kept as I said before this northern
access point is to become pedestrian
only and just just with one access point
from Church Lane just here the
pedestrian gate in the southern corner
that is to be retained and this blue
hatching here that is the proposed open
space contribution seven affordable
dwellings are proposed these are marked
with the Stars the red ones are shared
ownership and the blue ones are
affordable rent they have been spread
out through the site so they're not all
clumped together which which is quite um
there is a good mixture of dwellings on
site the blue color indicates one
bedroom bungalows the green one is a
two-bedroom bungalow yellow are two
bedrooms houses orange roomed house
purple is four bedroom house and the red
ones are five vacant houses so just in
summary this to one bedroom bungalows
one two-bedroom bungalow or choose three
three-bedroom houses three four bed
houses two five bed houses and the
conversion of the existing house into
the sticks apartments equates to two one
bedroom and for two variant there's also
provided within the conversion specific
apartments for over 55
looking at the site in a bit more detail
this is the northern tip of the site
these are the affordable dwellings that
were highlighted before and their
parking is arranged just here this one
glows that share a boundary with cedar
close and just the top of the open space
just they these are the affordable
swellings are quite close to the
existing dwelling that will become the
six apartments this is the access point
under Church Lane this is the southern
tip where the pedestrian access onto the
right-of-way would be this one shows the
same thing just with the open space
marks on it and this is the eastern
corner and there is a pond just here
which is the lowest part of the site
this is the open space it is a slightly
Tring to what the members would normally
see there is no play equipment proposed
because of the wooded nature of the site
and possible damage to the tree roots
through its construction the developer
has offered three picnic benches and
three sitting benches also pathways
which you may be able to see just
marching the green dotted line which is
proposed to be finished in bark chips
this would allow the members of the
public to come in enjoy the space and
look over look over their views to the
river this just shows the benched in a
bit more detail three picnic benches
just in this corner here and then three
seating benches just around that so that
people can really count
this is the tree survey showing the
trees to be removed marked in red as you
can see in this southern part where most
of the mature planting is hardly any
trees are to be removed at all there are
sections up here which are shown in red
that will be removed and that does need
to be so in order to to make the
development happen they are considered
to be a lower grade tree as I say most
of the mature planting is in this just
moving on to the plans this is the
proposed street theme just flicking
through the house types these are the
the two-bedroom affordable rent
dwellings three-bedroom affordable
dwelling this is a market house these
this is of market house pal and this one
five bedroom dwellings and the other
pipe these are the one bedroom bungalow
and this is the three-bedroom bungalow
the conversion of the existing house
would be like this with one unit here
another one here and this one here this
is the ground floor and the ridge is
proposed that they offer that over 55
they're all at ground floor level so
there would be easy access for people
with mobility issues the market
apartments are on the first floor and
just split into three in the same way as
below the dwelling is considered to be
an undesignated asset a heritage I said
sorry and minimal changes have taken
place to the fenestration the heritage
team are happy that this is not
attractive from the character of the
existing building
moving onto some photographs of the site
it is quite a difficult sight to
photograph because of the trees so and
most of the photographs are taken from
outside of the site looking in which is
the easiest way to sort of show because
the aerial photographs are probably more
helpful in showing you what's actually
on the site is such this is the existing
northern access point that would become
the pedestrian access this is looking
north in church lane from that northern
is best point you can see that it is
quite a narrow road
it is looking south towards a church
which you can just see the tower there
is also that second access that will
become main access point to the
development just there this is just
going back to them more than access
point these trees here are to be
retained with the affordable housing is
being set back here and the car parking
area thank you
this is just showing you the wall the
fronts Church Lane this is the second
types s point which will become the
vehicular access and you can just see
the dwelling in here moving down so our
site is where these trees are and as you
can see rabbit is quite an elevated site
these are the houses in Cedar close this
is taken from the public right-of-way
bit further down towards the village um
seated closes here and that these trees
are the area that would be the public
open space moving into Cedar close a
right-of-way is on the right-hand side
of your photograph again these are the
trees to be retained in the public right
the public open space just turning
around a bit and see the trees
and this is looking down towards the end
of cedar close with the public open
space here you can probably just see the
land levels and how elevated societies
are compared with cedar closed just here
is around where the land lies for our
site this is taken from cedar close are
looking into the site and this is the
area to be developed so the right-of-way
where the other photographs were taken
is on the right-hand side and you can
see that this is a much more open space
with poorer quality trees lots of
conifers and the they're not big
specimens like in the southern half of
the site there have been concerns raised
about residential immunity this is such
as evolved over the course of the
application and the revised layout has
the three bungalows along this boundary
here there is a four bedroom dwelling
proposed probably just about here
it has an oblique view because it is set
up so it would look across the garden of
this particular property but with
planting proposed actually in the garden
and anything along the boundary edge to
be retained
it wasn't felt the first-floor windows
would cause an overlooking issue that
would be detrimental to this property
just looking a bit further back just so
that you can see a bit more context of
site and his elevated position against
theater closed
issues that have arisen during the
course of the application include the
loss of trees landscaping banked ecology
protection and also the impact the
setting of the heritage assets these
have been addressed by the amended
layout with the development being in the
northern section of the site file sewage
has been a concern and Anglian Water
have confirmed this but main sewage does
have capacity for the development the
Anglian Water consultation response can
be found in your table papers there is
no identified need for new housing in
Brenham the need has been addressed by
the other developments one of them quite
large at the southern part of the
village so all of the need has been
addressed the strategic housing team
have confirmed however that there is
currently a district-wide need for eight
hundred and forty four homes fourteen of
these do have a connection to Brent them
one two and three-bedroom properties
although there is no identified knee
scheme does offer a high percentage of
smaller and lifetime homes of which we
know there is a district-wide need this
scheme would offer seven affordable
units this is a unique site and offers a
landscape and ecology management plan on
land that is currently without
protection of its trees the public open
space is also a benefit and would allow
local people to enjoy this special site
with long views over the river and to be
within setting which would offer a huge
amount in terms of biodiversity this is
a full planning application with a
developer who is very keen to start
building we have received a signed
deliverability statement from the
developer who has confirmed convinced
commencement within 18 months within the
first year it is anticipated to do about
eight of the dwellings a further eight
the following year and then five the
final yay although the site is outside
of the built-up area boundary
it is well located to access facilities
by foot or bicycle within the village
such as the school and the co-op store
all planning issues have been addressed
apart from the local need this
application is recommended for approval
with conditions set out on page 67 thank
you Thank You Samantha
members are there any points that you'd
like clarify used by the case officer
the NOC debate these are just for
clarification yes I've got councillor
Jameson open space no all of the trees
are to be left as they are and this was
one of the reasons that there's no play
equipment proposed on the site just just
the picnic benches and the chip the bark
chip footpaths bleeding through the
woodland area so there will be please
covering the open space yeah absolutely
yeah everything stays as it is okay
thanks there was quite a few trees there
wasn't the one we walked all around it
so many different parts any other
questions for clarification
no thank you
might ask the wooded area on the south
side what arrangement as you as they go
forward is there for retaining that as a
as a wooded area I mean what protection
is there against that being developed
there is a landscape in ecology
management plan we do need some further
details which we can we can have that by
condition that is one of the recommended
conditions in my report and that does
protect the whole site not just a
southern part that the whole site in
general mainly because of the mature
trees but all
the amount of ecology that is actually
on the site thank you
there's no one else wantin to questions
of clarification so we'll now go to the
public speakers which is the parish
representative Sarah Keys you have three
minutes in which to address the
committee so you'd like to start now
that's fine okay thank you thank you for
giving me the time to speak to you today
and on behalf of in parish council I'd
like to inform the committee that the
parish council recommends that this
application is reviewed the parish
council shares many of the original
concerns that were highlighted by the
Weber District Council Planning policy
team stated that the site unsuitable
reasons for this included that there was
unsuitable access to the site from
Church Lane although there is a posture
of is located within 800 meters there is
inadequate pedestrian access to this
service the site is located within a
proposed extension to the area of
outstanding natural beauty and will
create a significant impact on this
landscape
the council has particular can about the
impact of the development upon a number
of trees and their setting and there
would also be historic setting impacts
and potential archeological impacts the
proposal does insensitivity integrate
with the existing pattern and form of
development in the local area and is at
odds in the wider spatial context in
addition Branton parish council has
concerns about the available local
infrastructure particularly the
necessary addition arrangements in the
event is planning permission should be
granted however brethren harsh council
would be keen to see that this
application demonstrates a viable
commercial interest in the current
provider of social housing who is
prepared to support our element of the
project the parish cow has concerns
about the gardens of
Wellings that edge properties on feeder
clothes and in the event the application
is blinds would suggest that these
borders should between the trees and
planting to provide a visible boundary
between the parish council notes that
plots nine to twelve area that they
might missing in order to achieve back
developments the council would request
that in the event accessible these plots
are maintained in futures solely for the
use of the housing phone on the plan the
council suggested covenant by the
developer for this purpose which would
be the best way to achieve this the
council notes that the proposal layout
these open areas of amenity or landscape
use and the council request that if
permission is granted those affected as
such would not be available for further
erosion of the proposed area of
outstanding natural beauty landscaping
thank you very much No thank you Sarah
Keys members is there any questions that
you wish to ask the public speaker
Chancellor Jamison Jamison so no no
sorry no Jen can I could I just jump in
yep sorry I couldn't talk fast enough
chair so I do apologize miss keys hello
good morning or good afternoon now could
I term what engagement the applicant has
had with the parish council over this
proposal and spoke to the public and the
council at that opportunity thank you
any other members wish to asked any
questions no okay thank you very much
Sara please right we'll know there's
no objector now so we'll now go down to
the agent Sophie kittens
you also have three minutes in which to
address the committee at times thank you
very much and good afternoon members the
proposals were banned from place of the
culmination of some three years of
liaison with local residents and your
officers in a scheme which would deliver
a development providing unique benefits
for both new and existing residents of
Brantford village in the form of a mix
of housing within an attractive wooded
landscape including public open space
and picnic area the scheme has been
given detailed and considered scrutiny
by your office's receiving positive
support through both the pre-application
and processes the development has been
carefully adapted to reflect
consultation responses from both the
council and local residents officers
have found the scale of the development
to be appropriate for the village and
the tailored inclusion of apartments for
the over 55 shared ownership and
affordable properties would be a much
welcomed asset in meeting social
objectives Brampton place is set within
established wooded parkland and your
officers have concluded that the refined
proposals integrate well into the
landscape whilst protecting the woodland
and the site's ecological was the layout
of the scheme provides new footpath
links through attractive woodland and
public open space to join the existing
footpath network insuring the
development connects world to village
services in order to manage and enhance
the natural environment of Brampton
place great care has been taken to
ensure the whole of the woodland to the
south the site is retained and
sensitively managed as a key feature in
the landscape and to preserve the
setting for the church the provision of
a landscape ecological management plan
will make a major contribution towards
rural amenity by governing the long term
management of the wooded and open areas
ensuring that this part of the landscape
and potential area and beam will be
enhanced and preserved in perpetuity
whilst there will be some losses loss of
trees to implement the development the
majority to be removed or a either
Leyland I or diseased Elms which have
been evaluated by our consultants and
the council's tree officer and no
objection has been raised given the type
or condition of those identified for
removal indeed great care has been taken
in formulating the landscaping proposals
to ensure as many trees as possible
remain in City and that further tree
planting and long-term management will
safeguard and enhance the site's amenity
and create a sense
place the proposed layout protects the
immunity of established dwellings are
joining the site to the west avoiding
overlooking and loss of privacy to
existing residents the southern three
plots closest to see two closer
bungalows with minimum back-to-back
distances of over thirty meters through
periphery trees whilst the house on plot
twelve is some forty metres distant all
well in excess of design guide standards
retention of existing trees and strength
and boundary planting and further reduce
into visibility to summarize therefore
the proposals have evolved to ensure
that the development is sensitive to its
environment and will deliver important
tailored social and amenity benefits for
Brandt them these benefits will be
secured by means of a section 106
agreement I therefore respectfully
request members support for the officer
recommendation of conditional approval
in this case thank you thank you very
much on time right members is there any
questions who wish to ask the agent
I think cancel Owen have they got is
that on the fair on that on the ground
floor is that I only need for the over
fifty five or have on the upper floors
as well just having apartments on the
top floor hang on Allison it's the
question to the agent I think your
question to the agent is is the ground
floor apartments for only over fifty
five s and the up stays are not for 55
years so can you help on that agent and
if possible could I direct that question
to you
Edward Gittins who's the actual zuv
agent for the application and he'll be
able to handle that point for you
Thanks yes good afternoon yes yes that's
absolutely right the ground floor of the
Ransom place will be dedicated for the
over fifty five s so basically they're
designed to be older residents and
potentially disabled residents as well
and designed for that specific purpose
then there are
free-market apartment above that so the
over 55 provision is on the ground floor
as you suggest Thank You councillor
McClelland thank you
good morning Sophie or good afternoon
sorry I'm a bit confused with this
debate about the sewage can you explain
to me what the problem is with the link
with Anglian water systems I can't
actually answer that one I'm right that
TEAD kittens and basically there's no
problem and there's a manhole on site
that's been identified and originally it
was considered an angler water well able
to provide their response ahead of the
submission of the application so it was
left open to trying to establish during
course the application what the solution
would be if there was capacity but there
is a manhole cover in sight and and they
water have confirmed that there is
available capacity in the system for the
development can I just follow that so
are you saying that there will be no
need for septic septic tanks on site no
it doesn't appear to be the case now
given angular2 service that didn't come
out in the report actually did it was
unclear I think it was a it was a late
response unfortunately from Enghien
water and that some could probably
clarify that Thank You councillor Busby
yes when we visited the sites I felt
this was a very unique location very
unique setting and I felt it was almost
impossible to find a development that
could fit in harmony with it I have to
say that the developer has done a
remarkable job in delaying a lot of my
fears and in the redesign I think it's
very sensitively done the question I
have is that there's a lot of comments
in the report about police concerns in
terms of the parking and security
whether the developer has taken any
others on board
agent oh sorry
and and now I think it's it's an
architect design scheme which has
considered all all of the Paris sort of
elements there you know obviously it's a
well integrated scheme in terms of
parking and yeah any sort of security
details can be applied for as part of
collisions with secured by design
certificates etc at that point so I hope
I hope Jameson
yeah and from the Busby disaster the
exact question I was going on what is
the applicant doing in terms of
environmental sustainability through
housing so they put it in like renewable
it is a question to the agent yeah sorry
that sort of thing what are they doing
there yes those those sorts of details
can be provided again and that's
something that can be implemented by
condition and should members wish to see
it the the building regulation stage of
the development will sort of make sure
that the development adheres to
appropriate environmental standards sort
of wherever possible and so yes that
would be sage and she should be granted
I think I'm right in saying that I think
the committee generally likes to see
electric charge and point surges or made
available on-site where it's possible so
if there isn't any can that just be
looked at with the offices would you be
happy with their agents and yeah
absolutely we'd have no objection to
that whatsoever and yeah happy to head
in that direction is sort of responsible
developing forward I think it's going to
be
more widespread thank you any other
questions elaborate thank you um the
hello Sophie is there the apartments do
they have their own garden space that's
you know just for their their their
apartment or is it communal um I believe
it's it's communal but given sort of the
sighted situation situated within the
sort of a very sort of heavily
landscaped area and sort of they sort of
open space amenity benefits sort of on
their doorstep which is obviously quite
unusual for apartments in this day and
age especially going through the current
the current climates sort of you know
it's a real benefit for them to have
access on their doorstep to that thank
you any other questions to the agent No
thank you very much then we'll move on
I'll just check with the officers was
there anything you picked up in the
questions you wanted to clarify um only
going back to councillor Busby's point
about the unique setting and this really
is a site-specific layout that has come
about by looking at the constable tee
responses that we have particularly from
the a OMB team because I know that
that's something that is of great
concern to brendham Parish Council and
you know the a OMB team are actually
really happy with the scheme now and
they don't feel that it will impact
because you know this development he
sits between existing development here
and here so this more open area that
gives the wider views into the landscape
is all protected but that's that's my
only point really thank you thank you
we're now moved to the ward meant
remember councillor McCoy if you'd like
to address the committee you have five
minutes okay thank you very much good
afternoon chair and members of the
committee has it really been
three years have been her in two minds
on this application from the start there
certainly were benefits but a list of
local concerns were provided in
consultation and I'm glad to say that
many of them have been addressed and in
the evolution of the application and the
applicant has been increasingly
responsive throughout to all these
points as it's been state as a dominant
location the site is very visible from
the river and from Cedar closest and the
Pippins as you were shown in the
photographs and the reduction of the
impact on heritage on trees on the bat
population the provision of a public
open space and the the parkland segment
to the benefit I think of the
application it's well designed for the
site the point is how well does it
interact with the rest of the area and
Branson in general I particularly like
though I think the report itself and I'd
like to give my thanks to Samantha
summers for delivering such a fair and
well-balanced report everything you need
is contained within that report let's
look at the individual context the
parish council and the public have come
up with very very good points as I say
most of those have been addressed but
they still remain one or two I'd like to
nail down the immediate area being
secured for the future the open nature
of the frontage and the area near the
church it would be important I believe
to have that secured in a covenant that
it not be developed in future much as
has been mentioned in the parish
councils comments on plot 7 or the 79 I
think it was as far as the council tees
go outside a lot of positives have
pointed out but there are some
objections and holding objections in the
in the context of this our own planning
policy team would not consider this
suitable site and they have similar
reservations on access on church now
members and visiting may recall that we
ourselves were blocked from reaching the
site by one of our own refuse lorries
and I think that indicates how narrow
the road can be there and it's not a
footpath access to the main road by n
means you are literally dodging traffic
all the way along it but all these
points said there are three possible
ways of looking at this I do think that
these are screening boundary treatments
the various provisions I would say all
the Consul T should be considered so
come down to the options policy CS one
is met cs2 with it's a requirement for a
justified need it is outside the
settlement boundaries are there any
exceptional circumstances I think that
has to be asked and as far as CS 11 go
convinced by the proven local need a
local needs assessment would indicate in
fact that much of it can be satisfied by
a nearby permission granted by this for
this very counsel at gravel pit lane at
the other end of the road where the bus
goes which is you know supposedly only a
short distance away well there is
already a provision for affordable
housing there so that would be the
options for refusal if you're inclined
to grant permission I would like you to
make some changes to the recommendation
recommendation one lists a number of
points that referred to again in
recommendation for what I'd like to
suggest is that the conditions in
recommendation one and to be covered by
recommendation for that would then
provide a measure of security on all the
points made by the various council T's
many of which I have heard answered by
the applicant today and the report as I
say has pointed that all together on
that basis I think you can probably say
that this site is as well designed for
the site and in relation to the
community to address those concerns on
that basis I think the planning balance
probably Falls of approval and I'm very
grateful to see this site not spoiled
completely thank you chair thank you
very much Alistair members have you got
any questions for the ward member thinks
okay thank you very
much there's no questions for the ward
member so when they go into debate would
like to start pencil airs hello
I know now it's a bad thing off no
that's fine that's right
well I think yeah thank Jeff and just
say thank you to Council and a core as
well for his a very eloquent
presentation there as well but could I
just ask of summers please Sam I just
need some clarification then around this
this business of need so the report is
quite clear that that the need for
Branson has been met so I think what
you're saying is despite the fact that
the need has that are you saying that
that need is a minimum and so therefore
but there's there's no need to stop at
that point and and this is a worthy
application for want of a better phrase
to to consider additional I can confirm
that there is no need in Brampton that
need is already being given by the other
developments the the planning committee
have already are given permission for so
there is no need so it does fail that
point in CS 11 just to make that clear
to members Thank You councillor power
did I miss you um yes I was going to
take you next okay
start start a discussion really and I
think it's interesting it it just shows
the difference that it can make with a
well designed space because it seems
that there is a little bit more support
for this and sometimes we do here where
people are concerned about the impact
but the impact of there seems to be
people seems to be at an acceptable
level and I mean it seems like it would
provide a really a track
place to live I mean those 50 over 55
departments I think if they just had a
very small outdoor space of their own
but then had the ability to enjoy the
wider public area without the need to to
maintain it then I think it's going to
be going to be a really welcome addition
to the the available housing stock and I
don't know whether the other needs that
have been met in the village have
catered for the that group of population
they over 55 albeit that there's only
three three units but you know I'm I
think this is a nice application it's
it's really haven't got any reservations
about it and councillor Hinton canceled
him thank you thank you dick you're
missing out our thought Lee Parker was
in pro I took him before right sorry
yep it's a difficult one really because
as the ward member says the way that the
development has been proposed in in the
grounds of the this large house is very
attractive I have to say that based on
the indicated drawings that the officer
put the developer is really shot himself
in the foot by producing some rather
ugly looking properties to actually fill
those that the actual layout of within
those within that area but I would come
back if I may to the point made on page
45 by Suffolk police which that deserted
over by saying that there will be a
security letter or something or other
book forward the police have got severe
register reservations about the layout
of parking arrangements and where they
should be and for the police in our part
of Suffolk along this what we call
bandit country along the Essex border to
be worried about something is tis quite
unusual because normally
they're quite happy to let people claim
off their insurance companies but to
have this is is as a concern I think
rather than weighs against the proposal
I'm glad to see that Anglian Water of
suddenly to society they have actually
got capacity there whereas on that paid
same page 45 they actually said we know
that the developers proposed it not
proposing to connect to angling waters
net well that implies that they were
going to reply in and say that they had
no comment so why have they suddenly
decided to say that they have got the
capacity if they want to come on board
it seems to me there's been some
obviously some crossed communication
there somewhere I'm also glad to hear
that there is no need within Branson
because it's been met by existing
approvals because on page 61 where
they're talking about local needs
assessment the document did not address
the actual needs within Branson and then
the strategic housing team were
confirmed that district wide need is a
hunt 844 applicants well that's two
years worth a little housing target so
there's an awful lot of need out there
somewhere but is it need or is it just
desire all these one and two-bedroom
plots if we come back to what councilman
Vaizey was saying on the previous
application about Cove e19 etc there's
going to be some mental health problems
developing if these people are isolated
in single bedroom properties because
there's nobody else there for them to
talk to if we have another shutdown as
severe as we've had just recently so
there are quite a few questions that pop
up on that the the questions that aren't
addressed within this report I have to
come back to one of my old chestnuts and
your Polly beats and groans from the
other members because they usually are
healthcare eats burke Holt surgery
serves Brant them up in inverted commas
because they have 12,000 people on their
list and only six doctors so a lot of
people have decamped to Manningtree
and even to Holbrooke and Dedham for
health service but they are all full up
as well health services are full NHS
have not commented this particular one
when they comment they usually talk
about increasing capacity but they are
talking about increasing building
capacity not increasing GP capacity and
we all know that GPS are short across
the whole country
so we've got to bear that in mind as
well the education contributions
presumably are for the primary school in
Grantham which is sort of half way down
the hill they've got some Porter cabins
in the GAR in the grounds of there and
there so
66,000 it's going to contribute I don't
know secondary school expansions 68,000
well that's a tease Burke Holt does that
68,000 cover the fact that the County
Council tried to take away the bus
service that would take people from
Branson to East Burke on six form
expansion presumably is stuff at one on
the outskirts of Ipswich but there's
nothing to say that those people and
neither state if they wanted to go for a
sixth form college the sixth form
education wooden tip over the border
I didn't as you know in this burg Holt
and two of my three boys went to six or
college in Colchester so alright stuff
at one didn't exist in those days but
there's some it's a bit of a woody area
around infrastructure capacity Church
Lane I would agree with that
councillor McGraw is a disaster when it
comes to motor vehicle transport I think
it was put there when people went to
went to church by horse or walked
because certainly it's not wide enough
really to sustain extensive vehicular
traffic and really the County Council
have just sort of glossed over that
particular path of fact of the
infrastructure by just saying that the
junction on to the B onto the AE 137 is
hasn't had any recorded many recorded
accidents well that's hardly an
endorsement for for our highways and
infrastructure policy so I've got some
severe concerns about this in terms of
the detail and I would like to see a lot
more detail in the record if we're going
to recommend approval in within the the
wreck
the conditions that are recommended here
to tie down some of these facts rather
than just leave them in the rather
woolly ether that we seem to be doing at
the moment thank you John for that fair
useful four pints which are picked out
which perhaps Samantha can try and
answer as highways schools National
Health Service and police could I just
say Samantha I'm the police matter and
we do ask them for comments they don't
often and in this case they have made
these views is there any way that
surveillance cameras could be installed
in a recommendation if we were going
down the road that we reminded to
approve it anyway Petra can answer all
those points
okay so health and education that will
be covered by sole payments it is up to
a Suffolk County Council to put those
bids in health care is one of those
interesting ones and it the AHS really
only gets involved on the really major
developments this is very very very
minor really it's 21 dwellings so they
they wouldn't actually comment on an
application of this size in terms of the
police we hardly ever get a comment back
from them that is positive that their
job is to account for the problems
oversight their particular concerns
about parking I I can understand their
points however on a site like this where
there's an awful lot of trees we do have
to be mindful can park the girls without
them compacting soil over the roots and
therefore damaging them so there's
certain things on this sites that
probably are not ideal the that it has
been designed site-specific so yeah in
terms of surveillance cameras I think
there's always an issue about who's
gonna be in charge of that who's going
to be watching and some people don't
like to be filmed so that brings
problems of its own it is purely
safety aspect and you say there's lots
of trees well people can hide behind
tree you know and I think the average
car that would be parking in some of
these areas wouldn't cause a lot anyway
that's just a few yeah and was there
something else as well there may be the
narrow road okay yeah yeah they were
quite happy with the use of church Lane
as I say is quite small development so
they didn't anticipate that big would
cause a problem in terms of highway
safety but of course on the other on the
other hand I think because they've
actually asked for thousand-pound
contribution towards the improvement of
the public right-of-way they were
anticipating that most people if they
had school children would actually walk
down to the school because it is so
close to the site thank you all right
any other members wanted to comment
because we're in debate no hello Peter
sounds like we it sounds like we might
be moving towards a vote if you haven't
got any one no one else and no one's
made any proposals one way or the other
well I will propose then that we vote to
accept this proposal
thank you do I have a seconder for that
please all right well in the absence I
will say yes I'll second it well I've
already done it now well suppose we all
accept you as the second of it right so
that proposal for and Bowie councillor
Barrett and seconded by councillor Busby
the officer Russell wishes to make a
comment at this point Thank You chair
just to confirm early in the debate
mention was made of the electric
charging points I just didn't know you
want to put that as a as an extra
condition I think that's very good
yes I would like to
that is that is the condition where
possible I mean one can't be
unreasonable about it but I'm sure they
could make all strenuous efforts where
they can get it
I say Samantha style it already is
Samantha would you like to comment yes
sorry chair that is actually that would
be covered by the last condition that is
listed in the report sustainable
efficiency measures right now is gonna
make mr. chairman that I think the
sustain the overall sustainability
criteria for modern developments would
cover things like electric charging
points and so the panels were applicable
but not surveillance cameras right okay
but there are a lot of conditions in the
recommendation just ask Sam how
confident she is that we can achieve all
of those conditioners yet quite a lot of
them do are about the landscape and the
ecology so yes
yeah I'm confident that all of those are
firing I think help well there's no one
else wanting to ask questions in the
Chatterbox so I'm assuming there isn't
any others then I intend to put the
proposal that was proposed by forgotten
already councillor Barrett and seconded
by councillor Busby all those in favor
of the officers recommendations as laid
out in your papers excuse me one moment
councillor and generally request that we
record people's votes because I am
concerned that we haven't approved very
much albeit that we have this morning
but we haven't approved very much lately
since February and I'm a bit concerned
about this so I think this this is
called for now if we haven't we've only
approved five since February
well the next part of what I was going
to say was that I was going to ask the
office
rub to do the roll call for totin so
that that way then they are they are
listed down aren't they Rob there's two
so under the Constitution the current
way we do it with the roll call has laid
out in the temporary arrangements from
the monitoring officer and allow us to
do a vote by roll call by doing that it
does not mean that the names of which
way members vote ordered its is in the
same way as a recorded vote so if
members each individual member can
request that their vote is recorded in
the minutes as such all week or there is
the possibility of I think it's a
proposer a second and three other
members of the committee if they so wish
if then all of it will be a recorded
vote in the same way that we would do
say the budget or yep that's helpful
Canterbury if you want to make proposal
that we have a loot on this then you can
and I'll say we get three other people
to support you hey yes I'd like to
propose that okay do I have a seconder
yes I don't mind second in there I think
everything should be recorded right then
it's proposed and seconded Oh need two
more don't I yeah we've had Mary and
myself that makes four for others right
so we got Allister so yes the Barrett
has proposed it counselor
Alice now seconded it because American
MacLaren's Ward's that point as does the
chair Peter beer we need one more person
chair to make five
somebody else no right okay
Kent Allah Busbee well done that's first
far you've obvious then yes mr. chairman
could I just
goodnight sorry mr. chairman can I just
ask Council of Barrett why she referred
to the fact that we'd approved so few
and therefore we had to start sort of
saying who'd voted which way and what
well I don't think we need to get into
for recorded don't and proposed and
things and she's now got three people
with agreed I don't think we need to go
down that road with respect chair I
would support councilor Hinton's
question they have actually think I
don't and the question is are we talking
about this vote or every vote people
talking about this vote certain the
owner support in this boat but canceller
Barrett do you wish to comment I think
it could become a matter of public
interest and and I think it should be
available to the public on this occasion
well yeah
on this occasion certainly I'll have to
decide when I second it I thought if
we're gonna record we're gonna record
every vote you know if we're gonna do it
we do it probably on this particular
patient specific for the budget which
has to be done but if you want a
recorded vote
it has to be done on each individual
case as a request because the current
procedure in the Constitution is it is
not recorded how each individual member
if it was to be a change to the
Constitution to say it was then that's
what we do in this circumstance but
currently the system does not work in
that sense
so as on this occasion only okay thank
you so just you're still happy to pursue
that then Alison thank you
so there are asked Rob to do the roll
calls for the proposal to accept the
officers recommendation and by answering
your folks will be recorded Thank You
chair so if you respond with four again
sustained tears for David Hinton yep for
Tony Parker for and councillor Stephen
play ball unanimous yeah and this is the
legal officer agreeing with that yep
thank you very much the vote their chair
I'm being facetious right right well I
think we've got to the end of the
applications for today members I think
that's everything I'd like to thank you
for your attendance and Baron withers
and your patience
we've got through another one thank you
very good bye
[Music]